Oh God.
Yeah.
So everywhere you'll,
Ohio folks stick together.
No messing around.
Yeah.
What is it about Ohio?
We live,
what is it about Ohio,
Ohio guys like Ohio,
Cleveland,
Columbus.
You guys all stick together.
Sandman is,
how are we doing man?
I just good people.
You know?
Even when you won the title,
they're like Gleevec.
We got a trip.
I'll wait til.
What is it about Ohio?
Why does everybody love it so much?
I Dunno.
I just think it's the mentality of people.
They just,
the people are awesome.
Um,
you know,
I don't like it.
Just hard to explain.
I think you just got to live there.
Like,
you know,
there's people that have lived in our
states and move to Cleveland or Ohio and
they're like,
Nah,
you know,
I get it now.
I see why you guys like you guys are
so like in depth with the charters are
awesome.
Like you guys love each other.
I'm like,
yeah man.
We just,
it's like its own nation.
It is weird.
Like Columbus in particular.
It's like one of my
favorite places to visit.
It's like one of the,
it's,
it's like I get the weather sucks a lot.
I get it,
but the people are so damn nice.
Like it's like overall it's like,
it's really good spot.
Yeah.
Actually I love Columbus drive.
Uh,
I had a bunch of a blurry nights.
They're well
down there.
I went to my brothers
and all that good stuff.
But I,
it's a,
I love Columbus too.
It's one of,
you know,
do went on there and especially for like,
we'd go down to the Arnold
and stuff like that.
Just checking it out.
And you know,
the head of the Kubota may fights and,
and our local shows to low,
we have lack of our coaches go
down there for a local MMA shows.
Remember when they used to
do the UFC with the Columbus?
With the Arnold?
Yeah.
There was a big event.
That was a bit,
I wonder why that stopped.
That was always a lot of fun.
No,
the one time that Strikeforce there,
that's when a round a
round with soccer up.
Sorry,
I suck at this.
This is my first podcast.
Be Gentle.
Yeah.
How the fuck is the heavyweight
champion of the world?
Never been on a podcast before.
I've been on podcasts like over the phone,
but not like,
yeah.
Yeah.
So,
um,
but I think it was a strike force is when
I rousy and Tate font and that's when
she had dislocated her elbow.
Yeah.
Is that,
was that one of the,
I think that was one of them.
Yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
Back in the day.
So what's it like walking around the
UFC heavyweight champion of the world?
How's that feel?
It feels good.
It doesn't really matter.
My household.
I'm like fourth on the ladder.
It's my wife and the two dogs and then me,
I'm there just to pay bills.
It's feels like that sometimes,
right?
Yeah,
the money machine.
But um,
so is everything good now you're
finally got a title fight.
He finally got a real challenger and
Francis and Guano on January 20th.
How do you feel about this?
I think he's a great fighter,
you know,
definitely.
Uh,
he brings it,
it's hard,
you know.
Um,
but you know,
unfortunately nothing's going to change.
I'm walking out with the
will wrapped around my waist.
I mean,
you know,
I'm excited for him.
You know,
he's getting,
he's getting shot,
but as long as I'm here,
no one's gonna be champ.
Damn.
You have to have that mentality.
What do you think about
him that's unusual?
Well,
like what,
what about him?
Other than the size and the strength,
what stands out?
I mean,
was power,
I guess know.
But I think everyone
in turn,
the heavyweight division mean
260 pound man to a 50 pound man.
I mean,
you know,
you're not supposed to be
hit by something like that.
And I,
you know,
JDF Rj Dsfr now stuff on my car.
I mean,
I got guys who,
you know,
do hard.
Yeah.
You know,
and uh,
you know,
he just thought he's a little while too,
which is,
that's tough.
You know,
sometimes you can't prepare
for that because just there's
punches you don't see.
It's like the punchy Allister
with that Wilde took swings wide.
Well,
I think that was a little bit
of both on both ends over him.
You know,
we were just going to be a little sloppy
and then just put his face right in the
lane and yeah.
Overeem's got a weird style now.
Right.
It's a different,
it's a totally different style
over the last couple of years,
you know,
but he does awkward stuff.
Know,
like when you fought him,
what did you,
how did you feel?
Well,
when I fought him,
he was like very traditional
and moving around running,
but like kept yelling,
keeping his distance.
I'm like,
oh,
hey,
cool.
It's a fight.
You know?
And then,
uh,
you know,
he tried that,
that,
or lunging down what kind of kicked in
my thigh and I grabbed it and time it
took them down.
But you know,
I mean,
I didn't watch the whole fight with Negan.
No,
but what I saw was he's
doing all these wild punches.
You know,
when he fought me,
you're still in the straits and you know,
he wasn't really,
you know,
I think was in Ghana,
it was almost like he felt
like he could not get hit,
which was correct.
Right.
So he just decided to be just completely
wild and unpredictable me through that
wild lunging left hand to start the
fight off and then got the clinch
immediately but wasn't able
to do anything with it.
Yeah,
I,
you know,
I don't mean I'll find
out January 20th thing.
I think I'll be all right.
But you know,
I have the best coaches in the world.
You know,
I'm,
I'm pretty capitol walking in there,
you know,
he's a big dude.
Throws hard.
I mean,
but that's every,
every way.
I mean,
it doesn't,
it doesn't take much.
Well,
the only time we've seen
him on his back was a,
which fight was it?
[inaudible] that was Curtis
plates took him down.
Yeah.
That was his first UFC fight.
Right?
Yeah.
That was an interesting fight.
Right.
You got a chance to see it,
but it's,
it's hard to see when it
guys real young in MMA,
it's hard to see a fight from three years
ago or whatever that was and then look
at him and say,
well that's the same guy
today cause it's not.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
I've definitely changed the past
couple of months ago for sure.
You know,
I think,
uh,
you know,
he's definitely gotten better.
There's no question.
Um,
but you know,
we'll see.
We'll see what happens.
You know,
I listen,
I'm going to different bro.
You know,
I'm going through when you always do.
Yeah.
Now this is January 20th and right
now what it was this December 13th or
something?
What's today?
The second.
Second.
Yeah.
It says number second.
No,
today's not the second one.
Tell you I'm talking about their fight.
Oh No,
today is the 13th.
Yeah.
So like how much time did
you have to prep for this?
Well,
I've been prepping and
y'all been working out?
I've been staying in shape.
And so did you turn to have a feeling
that January was going to be the card?
Yeah.
So like when the UFC lets,
you know,
how do they,
how do they do that?
How does that work?
Usually contact with Andrew,
like,
Hey,
this is what we're thinking.
You know,
I think you'd be ready.
So,
you know,
I was a little beat up after the,
the jds fight.
Um,
you know,
my shit and everything,
not just my shin by other things
and just had the heel up there,
tried it took me awhile.
Um,
you know,
I thinks things,
I'm just trying to hold
onto the belt and just,
you know how the fuck says that
all the time they fucked up.
Don't listen to that.
Don't even respond.
I think it's funny.
I think it's great.
Yeah.
That was crazy.
But uh,
he fought everybody.
Yeah,
it is what it is we going to do.
I can't make everyone happy,
but uh,
but yeah,
man,
you know,
I was,
it was to be up a little bit
and just have a lot going on.
So,
you know,
now here we are to jds
fight was interesting,
right?
Cause that Shin was swelling up.
Heart couldn't leave that like,
yeah,
I feel fine.
Austin.
I'm like,
man,
it doesn't feel right.
You know,
I just,
I could feel like the Russia like
blood in my Shin and I'm like,
hmm.
It gives me again am I get
checked it and I was like,
cool,
I got hurt.
I got to end this.
So I was like chasing down and finding
my opportunity and thank God I got it.
But it's so interesting that
after all these years in Nma,
a new trend surfaces and that
trend is the low leg kick,
the low leg kicks to the
Shin and the calf area.
It's devastating.
Now you saw it with Benson Henderson,
I think it was the first guy to really
bring it to the UFC and really make it a
big part of his arsenal.
But you know,
you're seeing it with so many guys now
at the low leg kick is just a giant
technique.
Sucks.
It fucking sucks.
Right?
Well you can't condition
that part of your leg.
It's not the same.
I think some people are different,
some people,
but it's going to be real bad.
I think so like for me it sucked.
It was terrible.
I go up the stairs after that fight.
It was like the hardest thing
I ever just trying to train us.
Look like your leg was broken.
Like it swoll up so quick.
I was wondering if you had like uh,
the fibula was cracked
or something like that.
Yeah,
my doctor is actually was super
pumped about it cause he can be like,
oh my God,
look off deep bone bruise is,
this is amazing.
You were so pumped.
And he's like,
he's a train with us.
So he's a,
he's a good dude.
And he just loved the show.
My coach and my coach was like,
oh,
that's awesome.
I'm like,
so what did he look and put it
on an Mri or something like that.
I think it was an extra
or something like that.
And he saw the pictures and he's like,
man has a deep bone bruise.
Like this is a deep,
as you get,
you know,
he's,
it's pretty bad.
Yeah.
It's amazing to me that,
you know,
you think of all the techniques in martial
arts that this technique becomes like
a prominent technique in 2016 2017 yeah.
You know,
I'm,
I'm still trying to work on my jab,
you know,
that's what I'm working on
right now in 2016 so over,
that can takes off for a while.
No,
but yeah,
it's funny.
Huh?
You know,
mixed martial arts,
there's one thing and then like,
you know,
when to started,
there was one guy who was a wrestler,
one guy,
Jujitsu won't gap.
Now it's trending and train
more and more and than,
you know,
you got guys who are like,
sprawl and brawl or,
yeah,
it's,
it's crazy.
We were watching the,
how the sport evolves.
It's amazing actually.
Well you,
you're an interesting case because you
are a guy who does everything right.
You're not a one sports specialists.
Like you didn't come in as a kickboxing
champ like Overeem or like Mark Hunt,
you know,
you,
you came into the sport with everything,
you know,
you are,
you're one of the new
guys were essentially,
you know,
your,
you do everything,
you know,
you're not,
you're not a specialist.
Yeah.
I,
yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
I mean,
I rest of my life and then,
uh,
you know,
actually it was,
it was my coach actually who made it
better because my started a training what
mixed martial arts.
He literally was like,
I would take everyone down.
Am I off?
This is easy to deal with Mario.
And he's like,
no,
me go.
He's like,
every time you say it takes someone down,
I'm going to stay in,
drag it back up.
So yelling how to flight.
I'm like,
oh.
And I just got a crappy out of me for a
while until I started like learning how
to use my hands better than,
than,
you know,
I took a little time off,
just do go and goes boxing
and now here we are.
When did you start?
And then they,
Ooh,
10 years ago,
nine years ago.
That's not that long
when you think about it.
And now you're the UFC heavyweight champ.
I took a year and a half
off just for boxing.
Really?
Just to learn how to
use your hands better.
Yeah,
it's probably a good move.
Right?
That was great.
Best,
best move.
I did.
Especially coming in with
a wrestling background,
but you have an overall
athletic background too.
Like you paid paid baseball,
you know,
you,
you were,
you were a multisport guy.
Yeah,
I tried.
I tried,
but uh,
yeah,
you know,
I definitely wrestle.
Uh,
you know,
the rest and does help me out.
You know,
Imma make sure you use that and you know,
I think baseball definitely
helps me out too,
just because of the reaction and the
way he uses my hips and stuff like that.
It definitely,
it definitely martial arts.
Yeah.
I would imagine.
I think that having a bunch
of different skills like uh,
like have you uh,
you,
I'm sure you're a boxing fan.
Did you watch the Loma Chenko
a got it gets fucking amazing.
What?
Gandhi.
I'll file.
I'm going to want to share.
Oh yeah.
He was wearing a sweater.
Go fucking crazy.
Chicago was okay.
I'm good.
There you go.
I mean,
what I thought was fascinating
about the commentary,
they were talking about
how his dad making him,
made him take four years off
and just do Ukrainian dancing.
That's how he got his foot work.
Really?
Yeah.
His father said,
do you want to be a fighter?
And he goes,
well,
you're going to take four years off
of fighting and just learn traditional
Ukrainian dancing.
Yeah.
I mean,
his fucking father is a wizard man.
Right.
Nailed it.
I mean they,
you know,
they asked his dad like,
when did you know that it
was going to be the champion?
He said before he was conceived,
Holy Shit,
that's some Russian chair,
Ukrainian dark,
my God,
late Soviet Union type shit.
Watching that guy through
lots of that dude.
It's like,
it's like,
it's like poetry.
I don't know,
it's just,
he's like,
oh everything.
Even body shots like it slides
out of the way a body shot.
He slides out of the way.
A body shots the way like a Muy
Thai guy slides away from leg kicks.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Like he's just moved so much different
than anybody I've ever seen box before.
And they're like,
well his last four points,
the coaches through the towelette this,
fuck this,
this is terrible.
I was fucking that dude.
I'd be like,
I'm done.
I want to walk her ring.
I wouldn't go around and I'm like,
we'll call it best.
I'm wondering what,
I think he's one of those guys,
it's like a bar raiser,
right?
Like where he's just raised the bar
where people look at what footwork is and
they look at that guy and go,
okay,
this is not just like moving around a lot.
Everything's so purposeful.
Like when he turned around them,
when Regati out,
like he put his hand on his head
and then spun all the way around.
We're going to,
I was like,
what in the fuck is going on here?
He's a smaller guy.
Yes.
What's going on?
That's crazy.
Like mind blowing.
Yeah,
because it's not like he got
out like struck by a bigger,
heavier power puncher.
Now you've got the shitbox doubt about it,
but he was just pop,
pop,
Double Jab pup up.
Oh,
it's over here.
I mean,
I just like watching that guy.
sorry,
I'm trying to comfortable here.
Ah,
yeah.
I mean just it's that guy just,
it's like I'm,
I'm so happy to be alive to watch this.
I was there,
you know what I mean?
I watch videos and they got
all dairy is right there.
Yeah.
I mean just the fucking
guy barely gets hit.
I mean there's no one like him in boxing
because what he's doing is he standing
literally right in front of
you and he's unavailable.
It's not like he's like dancing
all over the place and moving away.
He's doing some shit and it doing it
in a way that nobody else is doing.
Like Floyd had lotta shoulder rolls
and he's slick as fuck and Floyd stands
right in front of you too.
And He ties people up and shit.
But what Loma Chenko is doing is
just some total next level shit.
What he does,
his hand in hand drops.
You don't care.
You know,
he knows he can get out of the way.
Yeah.
He does a lot of very interesting stuff.
But I'm wondering like if we're
going to see this in the future now,
I mean,
you know,
obviously when Ali came along,
bunch of guys started imitating Ali.
Yeah.
You know,
and Tyson came along,
bunch of guys tried to imitate Tyson.
You always see that.
I wonder how many guys were going to
figure out a way to take that to the next
level.
Yeah,
I think,
you know,
I think some guys are going to
take it to like not to that.
I mean I don't know if everyone's
going to catch that level.
That's just,
well that you know what the next level
is that but with like Roy Jones Jr power.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Think if someone figures out a way to
move like that with that kind of footwork.
But that one punch,
go to sleep,
you know,
knock out power.
That'd be sick.
Yeah.
That's probably the next level.
Hopefully I'm alive for that too.
We'll see it.
I mean this is a amazing time for,
for all combat sports I think.
I think the bar,
like I think with all sports,
right?
Like if you look back at the olden
days and you look back at today,
the athletes are bigger.
They don't know how to train better,
they're faster.
But I think anywhere that's
more apparent than MMA,
I feel like MMA is like the best
example because it's so new.
Yeah.
I'll have her send it.
Even like you said,
it's always something always evolving.
Like,
you know,
I mean like,
like was it John Jones,
you said a teeth to thei think that,
you know,
got a couple years ago and then they
started when we started doing it.
And then you're like
Benson Henderson doing,
you know what I mean?
Just,
I dunno,
I just,
I just love it because
it's always evolving,
you know?
I mean you were like,
you literally cannot take like two months
off and if you do it people are going
to pass you off.
Yeah.
And it's interesting too,
it's like there's different
schools of thought,
right?
There's like the Aka school where you
have all these killers in one room and you
have like world champions beaten up world
champions and then you have your gym,
which is much more specialized.
You know,
it's like you're the big
guy to emerge from your gym.
And then it's been Jessica,
I and some other high level MMA
fighters coming out of your gym.
But that's a,
like a lot of people think
that's the way to go.
To have specialized training.
Like Max Holloway has
specialized training where like,
you know,
there's not,
you're not dealing with a bunch
of people that are already champs.
You're building champs.
Yeah,
that's right.
We're a lot like at my gym is awesome.
Like my coach Marcus
Mare Ma Marinelli yeah.
It's like all home grown man.
Guys come in and he
just makes them better.
We all,
uh,
you know,
even like,
I don't get any specialized
training like anyone else.
Like I don't go out,
you know,
everything's pushed aside because the guy,
like,
like if he's got to fight,
they're going first and then I go,
you know,
I'm,
I'm not better than anyone else.
Yes.
He weight champ.
I don't,
I don't look at it that way.
I look at like,
all right,
you got a fight coming up,
you go first,
we'll push my training back later.
I,
you know,
like,
I don't care.
But yeah,
like,
uh,
it,
it's,
it's great watching,
like,
you know,
our gym,
like guys coming in,
they're like,
oh,
Hey island chain.
And I was thinking like to come out
like a few months later and you guys are
killing it and you're like,
Jesus,
like,
you know,
we have a,
we have a Kenyan Alexia,
I two have 500 kids in animal.
Like he keeps me young.
I had to like,
he's like,
he just turned pro.
He was third pro fight.
And I'm like,
God Dang,
I come in some days.
I'm like,
all right,
isn't it an interesting
how there's guys like that?
And then Jim,
and then for whatever reason,
it never clicked for them.
Like there's some guys that
are just so insanely talented,
but they just don't have whatever it is,
whether it's focus,
the,
whether it's the discipline to keep going
when things get weird to just finally
realized their potential.
Like what separates a guy like that?
That's like a gym killer from a guy like
you who can perform one of the bright
lights.
You know,
when I,
uh,
when I was fighting,
you got to see,
and I don't mean the whole story here,
but,
so I was thinking on fighting.
I,
I was like nine,
no,
I lost the struve and I,
you know,
I thought I was unstoppable
and it's true of beat me.
I'm like,
I almost didn't want to fight anymore.
I was like,
I don't know if I'm
ready for this anymore.
And then came back forward and Nelson,
y'all got a couple more fights
and then I lost the jds and Lilly,
when I walked in my
bag and my locker room,
I was just like,
I'm down.
And I'm like,
I don't even care anymore.
Like I don't even care what happens.
I'm gonna go out there,
I'm going to train and I don't
want to do is put it all out there.
But when,
when I'm gonna lose and
I don't really care,
it is going to happen.
It's gonna happen,
you know,
but I'm going to go out there and get
my damn this to win and want to do
whatever we gotta do
and I just don't care.
So,
but some,
so something switched in your head.
We,
you can kind of see it like
when you're doing this,
one of the things I've
always said about you,
but when you walk out the fights
and during the stare down,
you're like stoic.
You're like,
you give them dead eyes.
You just like you,
like you're there.
Here we go.
Like when you fought for doom,
when you fought for Doman Brazil and
knocked him out in the first round,
it's like you look at it your
face while you're standing there,
it's like you,
you might be waiting in line
at the fucking car wash,
you know?
I mean,
you could be anywhere.
You're not,
you don't,
you're not mean mugging him.
You,
you've,
you almost got like that fate or
face going on or you're just like,
hey,
we are.
Yeah.
You know,
I get,
I think at the dead fish from my,
when my wife yells at me,
no,
no.
I,
yeah,
yeah.
Just,
you know,
I just,
I looked at it a lot.
Really.
I was,
I just stopped caring.
I'm like,
you know what,
I'm not going to like over
like get emotional about stuff.
Like,
I don't care.
Like all I care about,
I was like,
I'm married,
I got a beautiful wife,
she takes care of me.
End of the day,
no matter what happens in this fight game,
she's going to be there for me.
She likes me for who I am,
not because I find she likes me,
cause you know,
I make her laugh.
I,
you know,
do good things for her.
She does good.
I mean,
just like,
like a marriage should be.
And you know,
and like,
she,
she was there before all this,
you know,
all this stuff happened.
So like,
she's not like a,
what do they call it?
Uh,
what's that?
What's the goal?
Digger.
Gary Go.
Yeah,
I called them.
I would think of that.
I'm an idiot.
But I,
yeah,
something like that,
you know?
And she's been there the
whole time and you know,
that's what I love about her and,
you know,
and I just stopped looking,
anchored.
Yeah.
You know,
I just stopped caring.
I just like,
who cares if I lose,
I lose beyond.
I'm going to go out there,
but I'm,
I'm very competitive so I'm gonna go out
there and do everything I need to win.
Yeah.
Randy couture said that once he
was talking to young fighters,
you know,
saying you can't be worried about losing
the people who love you are always
going to love you,
not going to lose anything.
You're just going to lose a contest.
And if you're to ring into something
like a mixed martial arts fight,
someone's got to win and someone's going
to lose and you've got to learn from
those losses and you know,
some of those losses,
that devastating feeling like I'm sure
it was there for you after this true
fight that the rebuild from that
is what makes real champions.
Yeah,
definitely.
It helped build them a model
that she took my mom there,
she didn't go to the fight.
She never seen me fight.
But like,
so you're not,
you know,
in London they got those
big double decker buses.
Right.
So we're going back into my head like,
oh man,
like it's throbbing you.
I'm like,
Oh God,
this sucks.
I'm driving back and my Koser next thing,
when he was trying make me laugh of all
center talking and I look out the window
at the hotel and my mom
spoke to graduate like,
sure.
Like
I'm like,
I looked to my buddies,
man,
I'm fucking high school right now.
Like,
who does that?
You know,
and I get that great.
They're like,
made me feel better.
Like,
like you said,
like no matter what happens,
you know,
always going to be,
someone's going to be there no
matter what happens to the Oregon.
Love you no matter what.
Yeah.
Your family's always your family,
your friends,
always your friends.
And if they're not,
they would never really your
friends in the first place.
You'd probably better off that way.
Sometimes it's good to have some losses
just so you realize who's just going to
abandon you.
Yeah.
Right now it makes sense.
So do you,
do you have any mental coaching?
The Do,
do,
do anything like that?
Uh,
I did.
I did for a little bit back in the day.
Uh,
after that.
That is true fight.
I think it was a street.
I talked to the sports psychologist,
which it turned into about
a minute talking about
fighting the next was about my
personal life.
Had nothing to do with sports.
It's just really just all it talked about.
It just,
it was just by half an hour.
Just,
I did it a few times.
I walked there every time and that's
when I started getting an entire like,
why do I care anymore?
Like,
and stop caring and that
and I don't carry more like,
like what,
what was he trying to cheat sheet?
Sorry,
I'm a sexist.
I took immediately as soon as
the next person must be a man.
How could a woman no in anything
such a piece of shit.
What do you think when you think about,
uh,
like your,
that's,
that's a critical component in the
keeping your mental state together,
right?
That's one of the things that uh,
a lot of people will talk about.
Like the having a good
support group around you,
having a support system,
family,
friends,
real loved ones.
So in her examining that,
do you think she was trying to like
reinforce like what matters and what's
important?
You know,
I never actually thought
about it that way.
She just nosy maybe.
But I've known her,
I've known her for awhile now.
Shit.
Like we know.
I know.
Uh,
she,
I don't know.
I don't,
you know,
I thought about it,
but we just started talking
and she'd just be like,
so let's talk.
And I'm like,
right.
And I said,
talking about fighting,
I'm like,
Yo,
this and that.
And then I'd be like,
no,
I got my girlfriend into the
girl at the town was loose,
she's doing this then it,
you know what I mean?
And she's like,
she likes,
you know what I mean?
Nobody.
But with lily,
I walked down,
I felt like so much better and not
even just because of the financial,
I think it needed to
clear all our stuff out.
Just needed like mine straight.
They say that for people to go to shrinks.
Like if you go to a psychiatrist,
I never gone.
But if you go like the best
thing is just to talk about it.
Like most people just keep
things bottled up inside.
They don't have anybody to talk to
about a lot of the shit that's going on
inside their head.
Yeah.
That was my problem when
I was younger actually.
I,
you know,
like especially like my wife,
one thing that made us better was
that I communicate because I was like,
she'd get mad at me,
I'm like
holy.
And finally one day I would like the how.
She's like,
Whoa,
whoa.
That was like two weeks ago,
like called boundary,
you know what I mean?
I was like,
well you told me that,
you know,
and then now and now it's just talking
to that lady and just opening up more
than just when something bothers me.
I,
you know,
she hates it now cause I'm like,
listen,
you know you need to do this.
Like,
you know,
she's like,
oh,
what's up?
Tough guy.
You know,
you're a full time firefighter too,
as well as being the UFC
heavyweight champion.
How does,
how do you balance that?
Well,
I'm part time.
I actually had two departments.
Oh,
okay.
You know,
but just uh,
he's just tough.
It can be in full time.
Yeah.
I didn't get hired full time so
I couldn't be tough to do both.
You know,
if I did before I'd be a lot easier.
But I can't just take a test because
you have to probation and year long and
then you can't.
Right.
So while you're fighting,
you work part time.
And do you have it set up where you know,
like you tell them in advance like,
hey,
I got a January 20th fight.
Yup.
I already picked my schedule.
So a month in advance,
like one station and I pick it within the
first week I picked my whole the whole
month and then the next
station we go like,
you know,
seniority.
So when I come up I pick my
schedule so I make sure that,
you know,
it's when he picked out.
So I really work by five
times in about two weeks now.
12 hour shift.
How much does that get in
the way you're training?
Never.
Never?
Nope.
No.
How's that work?
Just because the way I picked my schedule,
if I had to do,
I could trade someone and someone's
coming in and make it work and they're,
they're,
they're amazing people.
Both stations were amazing.
They're,
the chiefs are great.
The guys that worked that,
I mean actually a lot of
them are coming to the fight.
Jerry touring this song.
Yeah.
Well that's
a,
that's an interesting thing
about firefighters is that
a lot of times you get
those 24 hour shifts,
you know,
and where,
you get a chance to work out,
you can cook,
you know,
hanging out with guys.
It's like once the,
the duties are done around the firehouse,
right?
Yeah.
I play a lot of call of duty two.
They're losing a 10 year old kid.
It's a crazy job because when,
when you have to do something,
what you have to do is so extreme and
what's demanded of you is just insane.
Like I'm sure you've been paying attention
to what's going on just a few miles
from here in Ventura.
It's out of control nor,
it's crazy is that we just went past,
there was at Getty Boulevard Getty Center.
It looked like it was like,
I'm forgetting and then we just
pass it today and it was like burnt,
you know,
it was not,
it's like a couple of days ago.
That's what it will look like.
I mean it was like shocking.
Well La is a fucking mess.
You know,
the beautiful thing about California is
we don't have any weather in it never
rains.
But the terrible thing is once it
gets crispy and the other night,
you know,
when this was all happening,
uh,
I was at my house and the
wind was blowing like we did.
They were calling it a dry hurricane
because the wind was so crazy.
Trees were falling down all over
the place and the thought was,
man,
if a fire gets lit here,
we're fucked.
And then boom,
they start popping up.
There was a natural like from different,
no,
I don't think so.
I think there's a lot
of psychos out there.
I think there's a lot of fucking people
that recognize these are crazy fire
conditions and they just want a light,
something on fire.
And they do and they step away.
And then next thing you know,
it's a 300,000 acre fire.
It's crazy.
There's accidents for sure.
But I think for sure some of this
is arson within a day or two.
All those ones.
That's kind of,
how is that possible?
Yeah.
There's a bunch of
fucking psychos out there.
That's what I think.
I think there's definitely some accidents
and obviously those wins exacerbate
anything that would
have been a small fire.
Like there was a small fire in my
neighborhood a couple of months ago,
but it wasn't winning.
The firefighters jumped on it
quick and they put the house down.
Um,
but man,
when the winds were the way they were,
when you were having chunks of
embers that were flying six,
700 yards away,
flying through the air,
this and that and everywhere,
there was no way they
can stay on top of it.
That's,
that's,
that's like scary.
You know what I mean?
They're fine.
Like,
we don't want,
I mean,
we have like brush fires.
Yeah.
Well that's a good thing about Ohio.
We are right now we've got,
think we got like six or seven inches.
Yeah.
The snow.
So yeah.
Listen,
man snow,
you just need snow tires,
you know,
warm clothes,
no tires.
You're good fucking firestorm.
It's not good.
Yeah.
I mean that,
that's,
that's like,
Oh God,
that's scary man.
Like just,
just reading about it and just
seeing it and seeing the pictures.
Just,
you know,
you feel terrible for people.
You know,
we actually have friends in San Diego.
They had to get evacuated.
He said there was 85% chance that
their house would be be be gone.
Jesus.
He came back and within a 10th
of a mile of the fire stopped.
They're got lucky.
Yeah.
I've been evacuated twice.
That's scary.
Yeah.
It's scary.
But you know,
you just got to get out quick,
throw the dogs in the back,
let's go fuck it.
You know,
part of it's like cleansing.
Look,
all that stuff in your house is not you.
You're fucking TV or your clothes.
That's not you.
You're,
you.
Yeah,
you'll be all right.
Which I listen,
I always buy a new one.
Yeah.
Just fucking stay with your
grandmother for a while.
You'd be fine.
Everybody live.
As long as you get out,
you're all right.
You'll be able to rebuild and get back.
It's sometimes it's a,
I mean,
it's not a good thing to lose
everything that you work for,
but sometimes it's a good thing
to know that you are vulnerable,
you know,
like in these,
these fires,
like I think it's one thing
that La is missing is um,
humility that's brought on by the weather.
I like,
you know how it is an in Cleveland when
it fucking snow's right when it snows
out and it's thick.
There's that feeling in the
air where everybody calms down.
Right?
Everybody's like,
okay,
like there's no one driving like a
fucking crazy psychopath when it's snow.
Everybody's going real,
kind of slow,
slow and steady.
Your back tires are
kicking out a little bit.
You know what I mean?
Like that,
that keeps people humble.
Yeah.
We actually,
uh,
was it the weekend of what it,
where's One New York,
Madison Square Garden?
Which means that you'll see what,
what was that,
what number was that?
I don't know.
Whatever happened,
whatever,
whatever it was.
Um,
so I'm coming home.
My wife's like,
Hey,
you know,
there's a huge storm coming.
Just like,
you know,
all my cool.
She's caused me again at my house.
We have actually a built in generator,
so if the power goes out,
oh,
that's nice.
Sweet Dude.
Awesome.
So every Saturday I
would hear it kick out.
I'm like,
awesome to think works great.
Of course the tower needs to work,
the power goes out is dead.
The battery busted on it.
But,
so we came home and I came home and I
flew home that night and it was like a,
like a Zombie apocalypse man.
It was like stuff everywhere.
Like it was all dark.
There's trees like on top of it was crazy.
And then they said that 15
ton of tornadoes touched
down within between Indiana,
Ohio,
and uh,
an IPA.
And so we came to my house
and there was like half,
I have one big tree in my yard.
I have eight and a half acres at one big
tree that magically got split in half.
Wow.
Then our barn,
we have a barn.
It's like,
it has like software on the side of that
all got like half of got ripped down
that it was,
it was crazy.
Like,
I mean there was like so much stuff.
Fine.
We had a [inaudible]
black got ripped down.
Like,
you know,
he's like you're saying,
but yeah.
But it,
you know,
you said it's,
it's humbling because you know,
you're not safe.
So I believe we can find out that the,
uh,
generated and working
on that we're getting,
because it actually worked in their day,
the power,
and it was so windy that the power
went out and actually kicked down.
I was like,
oh yeah,
there's something that like,
that's comforting about hearing that.
When I lived in Colorado,
we had a generator,
the power go out and you're
like,
Ooh,
I'm okay.
I'm safe.
Yeah.
Are you handy?
Do you fix shit?
Like buddy,
my buddy Rick,
it actually,
he was over the other day.
I was like,
hey.
He said,
what's that man?
I'm like,
Hey.
And I'm like,
what are you doing?
He's like,
I'm calling your house,
but uh,
what?
He's like,
yeah,
talk to her.
Why she needed to fix something.
I'm like,
all right,
cool.
I'll see you at the gym.
She comes over and does that for me.
Oh,
I mean,
I do help them out,
but it's mostly,
it's all him.
He'll lucky,
lucky.
Didn't know someone who could fix shit.
Yeah,
I'm terrible at that stuff,
man.
I'm like,
I make it worse.
Well,
especially if you live in a place
like where there's fucking tornadoes,
like can you,
is there a tornado proof house?
Can you make a house like a number,
like three little pigs.
You remember like the guy with the bricks,
you can make it,
you have to figure it out or you can
make a little shout out to the ground,
I guess.
I don't know.
I don't like a little,
like a little doors and I have no idea.
Right.
Like wizard of Oz type shit I guess.
Yeah.
You'd have to go,
you'd have to make something that
like was underground some underground.
Does it do to have that member?
Remember when we were kids,
like a lot of guys had a,
like not a lot of guys,
but people were talking about building
bomb shelters in their backyard.
Yeah.
That was like a big kind of day.
I kinda like that thing.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I,
well my basement's print,
it's not bad.
It's,
it's got a few like cinder windows,
like the right,
whatever.
That's about it.
I mean,
so you'll probably survive down there.
Plus we have like a little area and then
two with like with like the furnace and
stuff so he can hide in
there and nothing will,
do you workout at home at all?
No.
God,
no,
no.
I actually,
I have a,
I have a 300 square foot barn with Raby
heats was like warm all year round.
You know,
it's awesome.
And it was like,
dude,
you should put a cage
in there as a training.
I'm like,
Hell No.
this is my sanctuary.
This is where I go.
And I watch TV and I
relax and I do fun stuff.
You know,
like,
no,
I'm not bringing anything.
My wife does,
my wife,
you know,
she has a some honest stuff.
We have it,
a little kettle bells and her,
you know,
stuff like that.
She loves it.
So,
uh,
you know,
share the treadmill yet and
she just does her thing there.
Yeah.
Um,
that's probably a good attitude,
right?
To burn it all out in the
gym and then home is peace.
That peace was,
that can be,
you know,
if I piss off the wife
and it's not so peaceful,
how do you,
like when you're the UFC
heavyweight champion,
the world,
like that's a tremendous
amount of pressure and stress.
Play some call of duty.
I don't know,
just to hang out.
I really honestly,
I just chill.
I don't do much like,
you know,
John Volante,
I man,
I played with him online with a bunch
of guys from New York and we just sit
there and talk smack,
Talk Shit to little kids and make,
make yourself feel better.
You know,
imagine you getting new shit if
you're playing online call of duty,
like UFC heavyweight
champions talking shit to you.
What the fuck.
I,
my buddy was actually,
we were playing with
[inaudible] and he's like,
goes,
look,
Yo,
Yo gonna come over and kick your ass.
I,
he's like,
let me do it.
And I'm like,
don't you consider where I'm like,
just let him have his moment,
you know,
come over and kick.
Yeah.
I mean I,
it's so funny to get direct
messages and stuff like that.
You know,
you're terribly threatening you.
Oh yeah,
you're such a noob and now you're lucky.
I'm not,
I don't know where you live.
I fucking find you and I kill you.
I'm like,
ugh.
It's so fun.
You imagine the thought that would go
through their head if they found out who
the fuck they were talking to.
Well,
the horror,
you're some 14 year old shit talk and get
all folk and to house stick my dick in
your mind.
Like
you find out you're talking to
the UFC heavyweight champion like,
oh Jesus.
Oh Jesus Lord,
what am I done?
Yeah,
yeah.
I remember we were at,
we were in Vegas probably like that.
Some guy had no idea,
like not being like talking shit.
But we went to like,
I'm a bud light party and that we want
them to like just him to him man Shannon
was like,
it was crazy.
It was having fun that like,
like bunch of different Elvis Presley's
wherever they are like always miles they
or I'm with my wife and we're hanging
out and I'm like sitting like they're
looking straight,
like not looking around because I
know that I do and girls might goes,
you know,
and so anyway,
I'm like got to be able to,
do you want anything on there
with some macaroni and cheese?
She's like,
yeah,
cause they were like,
we randomly met,
I'll never forget that macaroni cheese,
whether we get some Mac and cheese and
I came back and just be talking to my
wife and I'm like,
hmm.
I'm like it turns around and
we're here at and he's like,
oh I'm so sorry.
I didn't know.
Like he was being nice little life.
Like he's being nice.
He's just asked me what I was doing.
Like we had no idea.
I was with her younger disaster.
Yeah it was,
it was actually pretty funny guy.
Like they'll be like piss his pants.
It was,
did people treat you any different or
on the fire station or is it pretty
normal?
It's good.
It's gotten worse.
Worse.
Yeah.
They,
they treat me like garbage.
So I,
you know,
I always say like,
give me a plunger is like,
hey,
go to town champ.
How?
I'm like,
really?
You know?
Yeah.
They don't care.
That's funny.
No,
but they're good guys.
I mean,
I love them both stations that are just,
uh,
you know,
Oakland Valley view though.
Those guys are just,
they're just good guys.
They're just always,
you know,
like,
they actually,
when I fought in Brazil so
they couldn't go to the fight,
so they flew to Vegas and have their own
wash punting Vegas to watch the fight.
You know,
how convenient they couldn't stay in Ohio.
I go to bed,
honey,
I gotta go to Vegas to support Steve.
That's fine.
Vegas?
No,
no.
He's in Brazil.
But the hookers were in Vegas.
Yeah.
I got to go where I got to go.
No,
I mean,
honestly,
they're great guys.
I mean they're just,
uh,
you know,
as I,
we came champion,
they really don't care.
I,
I felt bad for him though,
cause like really sly,
you want to title on Saturday?
I flew in on Monday,
I got home Monday and I think
worked Wednesday at the state,
the one station and Lilly,
everyone found out and that phone
did not stop ringing the doorbell.
And they were like looking at me like,
are you serious?
You and other folks I suppose
to be taking naps right now.
Like,
you know,
Ding Dong,
what is the chilled bars?
So I felt like they understood,
but I felt really bad because like,
I want to relax too,
you know?
And they have like a
little prayed for you.
Yeah.
Well,
um,
yeah.
Well not a little parade.
It was a,
I wasn't there.
I wasn't like,
I was joking.
Oh yeah.
It was pretty big.
1.3 million or 6 million.
That's crazy.
It was nuts.
It was so hot too.
Like UFC,
he's like,
hey dude,
here's a,
here's a jersey.
I'm like,
are you serious right now?
We only wear this Black Jersey right now.
One of them.
Reebok.
Yes.
Oh,
it was so hot.
It was like 90 degrees and I'm like,
I was struggling.
I was was,
it was so bad.
But it was honestly,
it was cool man.
It was,
you know,
everyone's screaming and like it was,
it was so many people.
It was just,
just,
it was great to see,
you know.
There it is.
Yeah.
He's sweating like a pig.
Oh,
so there is,
is it weird like walking
around the street now?
Like what does,
what is a normal life for you?
Normal.
I'm a man.
Everyone's so nice there.
Don't,
don't like run me and like,
oh,
what's up man?
They're just like,
hey,
go see a champ.
Is there any,
do you think there's any
benefit of keeping a day job?
Do you think like in any way it's
like good for your head or anything?
I think so.
I definitely think so.
I think that it keeps me grounded because,
uh,
you know,
we don't always talk about fighting,
but like it just,
you know,
one of the things we're worried about
the worry about funding this Nacuso mine
off of it,
but,
um,
I think also too is always a plan B.
You know,
I feel like I could walk
out of here for trip and,
and break my hand.
I'll never fight again.
You just never know.
So that's why you keep the job.
They're a little bit,
but I really work hard
and make my mom proud.
Okay.
No,
I just don't.
Plus I love helping people,
you know,
my whole life I guess I would have been
helped and so it's my don't want to get,
cause I was saying about being a coast
guard police officer and my buddy's like,
dude,
check the firemen,
dude.
It's great job.
I looked at him like,
get full time 24 on 48 off.
It's awesome.
That's awesome man.
Like who would want to do that?
And then,
uh,
yeah.
So yeah,
but like some people would say
like to be at the top of your game,
you literally must devote all of your
time to it all the time and that you
wouldn't have enough time
okay.
To,
to work a regular job.
No,
I mean,
I make it,
I make it work,
man.
I got,
I don't care.
You know,
I,
I work a lot of Sundays.
I'll do 24 hours.
If you just hit the lottery tomorrow,
you got $100 million,
I'm out.
You'd quit.
Oh yeah.
But that's the point.
Like what if,
uh,
you know,
say you,
you continue your,
your title run and you
make more and more money,
become a giant superstar.
Like you deserve to be and you start
making those Conor McGregor checks if you
going to keep that job.
Yeah.
Really?
Oh really?
Yeah.
I know I hit ups for loans.
It's going to have had been there,
done that.
Every one of those days it's so bad.
I'm like,
I'm was my family.
Bro,
how I'm night my family are bothered me.
I'm like,
this is great.
But like I friends and stuff like Jesus,
really?
They want loans,
right?
Yeah.
That,
you know are not loans.
No,
nobody's ever paying one loan.
I only one I've ever get
out and it came back.
They came back and got lucky.
Actually it's that guy that looks like
my brother with a mustache or who?
Steak and potatoes.
Potato.
You know Tom About think my coach.
Oh,
the guy with the mustache that I,
last time I got to talk about I was,
is um,
when Schwab was here,
now it's his other buddy's name.
MMM,
okay.
What's his name?
Brian Cowen.
Yeah.
He was like,
who's that?
His brother or something.
And you're married in the Cajun.
Oh,
right,
right.
Yeah.
Actually stairs on business.
Health,
the mountain.
No,
he's the only guy I trust
someone that you're close to,
but it's always people that you kind
of like in the periphery that have some
stupid business idea
that you can't go wrong.
Yeah.
They can't go wrong.
Those are,
those people are my favorite.
This can't miss the idea.
I don't know.
I don't play that game.
I plus my wife somewhere in pretty
much in charge of the money.
That's good.
So that's good.
You have like removal from it like hey,
I can't even do anything.
I'm sorry.
I blame her.
And she's like,
she didn't even wear sneakers.
Yeah,
yeah.
I can't buy underwear for myself.
I went from,
and I saw it.
Who,
who schedules your training?
Like say if you're going to do a big
camp for like this in Ghana and fight,
like who schedules what
you do all the time.
Oh my coach Marcus.
You always use my sesame dies
or I'm with this guy here.
I went,
this guy,
I think we should meet this guy in,
you know,
and just,
we kind of just figure it all out.
And so does he have all this written out?
Like keep like a certain amount of rounds.
He wants certain amount of
strength and conditioning.
See,
so he's he or your overall trainer?
Yeah,
he's my head coach.
Yeah.
He's the one who
okay.
Figures everything out.
Boy,
my boxing coach,
Alex,
I have my strength conditioning.
Bobby.
Uh,
you know,
I've Steve,
the guy who actually know the mustache.
Yeah.
He's a grappling kind of more my,
when I do just kinda makes
you feel good about myself,
you know,
just fun dude.
Yo me,
I'd tell him apart and talk
shit to him and you know,
it makes them make themselves feel
better about myself and I'm like,
God,
you're so old and fat and like,
I feel good.
You know what I mean?
But I,
yeah,
he and Margaret,
he sets it all up,
make sure it's all good,
you know,
Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursdays,
and then,
you know,
as you Saturday they just
take Fridays off somebody.
How much strength and
conditioning do you do?
I don't do too much.
I don't,
not like,
I want to do like heavy lifting,
you know what I mean?
Because it's not a power
lifting competition.
It's a fight.
So like on Tuesdays I do a posterior chain
working for my lower back and my leg,
my half.
We have a Yo westside barbell.
Sure.
You know,
they uh,
bowed squat.
Yeah.
I do love that dog putting one in here.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Do to Louie Simmons is the bomb.
Good Dude.
I love that guy.
He's a freak.
He,
we had one of the best
podcasts ever with him.
He's so fucking crazy.
He's out of his mind.
My coach is like one of like the ogs it
within make you worked out of his garage
before it became like it is now.
Like he used to like just train
with them back in the day.
Yeah.
We went there and gave us a tour
and that whole belt squat thing,
that thing's amazing.
Oh,
it's awesome.
Like gets you traction and not so strange.
So I,
you know,
I do that,
uh,
under the new one that's
even awesome are now too,
which is great.
They can dead lift off of it and you can
do rubber bands like they're geniuses
over there and just do amazing jobs.
So I do a bunch of that
like reverse hypers.
Yeah.
I've got a reverse
hyper machine back here.
The pendulum swings real good too.
That thing's amazing.
Yeah.
That reverse hypers a back fix her.
I mean,
night and day.
It's the craziest thing.
I mean,
if you,
if you have a back issue,
ladies and gentleman,
please just Google reverse hyper.
It is an amazing machine that Louie
Simmons created and it literally
decompresses your spine and
strengthens it at the same time.
It is a work of art.
Yeah.
I mean I love it.
I mean you,
you,
she's,
I can't talk to him.
Excited.
Uh,
yeah.
There it is right here.
It's showing,
look at me motherfucking paper boy hat.
But belt squat they got,
it's,
that thing's amazing man.
But I feel like having that thing on you,
you would seriously develop
some like real power in your,
in your movements and your,
your ability to push off.
And I think for striking that
would be fucking incredible.
That thing.
Yeah.
I dude,
yesterday I did three,
five minute rounds,
uh,
to 90.
So do you a shadowbox
while you're doing that?
Yeah,
it depends what I do.
I a little shove out of the first one I
did marching and I slide back and forth
just a little bit.
I do,
uh,
it's Kinda funny,
but actually grabbed the
bar and I thrust my hips,
works my hips and have
to do my lower back.
And then next time we did
a with squat medicine ball,
throw it to one coach squat,
throw it back back and forth,
five minutes.
And then I'll know when I like bourbons,
keep me on just counting,
keep moving a little bit like that.
And then you evolve this over over time.
And we have,
we actually have a,
put it back up again.
We used to have a medicine ball that
was strapped up and be like a more Thai
clinch.
It's we did that,
you know,
the five minutes.
That was hard.
That was terrible.
And so that was actually not funded all
we did that and then we had like um,
these massive like
on what the weather,
I almost like part of a boat but there's
these big metal rings like Oval Rings
and their Chin.
I don't know,
we just sit there and just lock her like
this and keep your hands up high and
just,
just working on,
keep your hands up.
Plus we put it for the Max
in that you're a veteran max?
No,
what's the Virta Mac?
So it's like,
um,
it's like a,
it's like a platform.
The platform has got
all the straps number,
I'll resistance.
It's pretty cool.
So you can jump,
you know,
punching.
Oh,
you know,
I had,
I think I have seen that before.
It's like it strapped up to different
parts of your body so he could throw knees
and punches and kicks and stuff like that.
Yes.
We had that to that.
So it's a pretty interesting,
and you do operate on Brown's,
you do rounds?
We've done that.
I've been around.
Yeah.
So like when we go back and forth with
that and stuff like they can want to be,
I want to have you on when then
when resistance and Dah Dah Dah.
So are they,
do they monitor your heart rate?
No,
no.
I just pushed to the limit.
I don't worry about it.
You know,
like I do listen to my body if
I'm tired of 'em are struggling,
you know,
like the last camp for Jds camp,
I don't know what I was thinking,
but I did like,
I was already doing five,
five minute rounds within like
the first like totally so foot 10,
10 to 12 weeks for per fight.
And it was like fire,
like Oh yeah,
I feel good.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
And then like a week thing,
I was like,
Ooh,
I just died too hard.
Yeah.
I just was being just the dumb Jack.
Well that's what I wanted to say.
It's like,
like what is the,
not that you're dumb jock,
but like that is,
what is the,
what's the way you prepare for a,
like a major championship fight?
Like what is the buildup?
Like like how do you,
how do you know like
when to push too hard?
How do you know when you're peaking?
When to back off every fight?
Uh,
two weeks out I stopped swearing.
I don't spark two weeks before a fight.
Two weeks,
two weeks.
Why is that?
Just my body rest.
No worry about building my back,
hurt my body and stuff.
That's some reason I made that
jds fight cause I really like,
everything hurts so bad.
I would wake up in the morning
but just stretching outage,
they get to feel the pain.
Like just my bones now this
bar and just sorting that.
See I was just being
sore and then from spine,
from doing everything grappling and just,
you know,
I'm not boxing,
whatever.
And then uh,
you know,
if I had two weeks,
man I felt like $1 million.
So what you do for those two weeks out?
I do pair work,
conditioning running and stuff like that.
You know,
just uh,
just keep my mind straight my mind.
Right.
You know,
I work in a patch,
it's like technique going over
the game plan for the week,
you know,
everybody's got a different
strategy for that.
Like mad,
he was told me he would work out hard
right up until the day of the fight.
Like,
yes.
She's like,
that's what we've always done.
It's what I've always done.
It feels right for me.
I can keep puts his mind in a good place,
I guess too.
Yeah.
I mean I,
that's old school,
you know what I mean?
For him though,
he worked for him of all time.
Yeah,
no doubt.
But I talked to another coach who said
that when he was competing that what he
would do is the last week of the fight,
he literally wouldn't do anything.
He goes,
I wouldn't work out at all.
I go,
nothing.
He is nothing.
He wasn't my ride,
my bike.
He goes,
I might swim a little bit
because I don't do shit.
He goes,
I already know how to fight.
It was Marty and shape.
He goes,
I'm just trying to recover.
And he goes,
and you think about it like if you haven't
worked out in a week when you go and
work out,
you're like,
fuck.
It's like,
that feels so,
so powerful and energetic.
Cause everything's recovered.
And he's like,
that's how I want to be when I'm finding.
And I'm like,
okay.
I think,
I think that's how I,
you know,
I still go hard and he,
I to do my rounds and I,
you know,
I'm pushing the limit and,
but like,
you know,
I definitely just the last two weeks,
just let my body rest from
getting beat up mine right to,
you know.
Do you,
uh,
you have any sort of recovery methods?
Do you do like cryo therapy
or massage or ice baths or,
yeah,
I um,
I do ice baths on my own.
Um,
but I do,
I cry and I would place that
looks to be obstacle there.
Ben Cleveland,
I do Epsom salt pie once a week with a,
with a,
with a menthol.
I was always called Natalia,
that green menthol,
menthol cigarettes.
I think it's like,
well,
you know,
like come to the Er,
they can either put it at like
the Epson salt and light green,
like the g the liquid.
I don't even know what that is.
It's Epson salt,
but it's green.
Yeah.
It's like,
man,
these Menthol,
I have no idea.
I shouldn't have to pay attention to that.
You know,
who knows.
But,
but it opens up the pores actually
helps with people cutting way too.
But then she opens up beyond
it gets everything out.
And then,
uh,
I do that once or twice a week.
I think the crowd I want,
I want to start doing that here as soon,
once,
twice a week.
Um,
you know,
I proteins,
amino acids,
all this stuff.
You know,
you're supposed to,
I go to a chiropractor a couple times a
week and they asked that without sets,
including massagers.
So for 20 minute massage after.
So yeah,
I think massage is super beneficial.
I think the more people do that,
the better.
I think especially for fighters,
he just,
you're constantly dealing with knots
and things that could eventually become
like real injuries.
Yeah.
I remember one night I was supposed to
have Ben Rothwell and pull out a flight.
It was like worst time of my life.
I never pull out a fight before.
I didn't know what to do.
I feel it couldn't bend over.
Like I was like,
I never forget I dropped my wallet.
I was like,
what happened?
It's just my back.
It was so screwed up,
like I was driving,
I was pretty like sit up straight.
I felt like it was,
it was so bad.
I let my bag was so
messed up like I would,
did you get an Mri?
Yes.
So in my,
my,
my lower my,
um,
what else am I else?
For whatever else,
they were just screwed up their,
you know,
their herniated bulging out,
whatever you wanna call him.
And uh,
so I went and talked
to Tom from west side,
you know,
Irish guy,
whenever he's out,
he was like,
hey man,
check out is so ass.
SOS muscle mass muscle is no,
so it's a muscle.
It's connected on the
inside of your thigh.
You didn't tell your bone
when it goes over hipbone in,
it goes to your lower back.
Okay.
So I was sitting there and like,
I would like take your shit and I'm like,
oh,
like I feel like,
like my spine,
it would kill.
So I said like stretching it out
and say get massage and massage.
It was like,
she's like,
I'm like,
I'm not gonna lie.
She was like,
you touching your so s muscle cars,
they have to dig and get to it
cause like you just can't find it.
She was like a rubber
band was like bumps on it.
She was disgusting.
She was like,
it was the dance.
So I go to a
west and this guy named John
Quinn who is a release therapist,
whoever,
big dude.
Awesome.
Did he actually say my career?
He started working on my so ass
and started stretching me out.
Well I mean now I can do head kicks now.
I'd never be able to hit kick.
So it was like a muscle that's just was
broken down and it wasn't getting enough
for covering this wrestling from being,
you know?
Sure.
And then just being tired all the time
and then hurting my bag when I was little
kid.
You know,
not a little kid when I was 18 I my back
and then he just carried on and family
do yoga.
I did the,
it's tough for me
like,
Oh I,
of course it is.
Yeah,
that's why it's supposed
to be good for you.
Again.
It's hard to do.
I probably should do it.
It's just that it's tough.
I'm going to forget.
When I was training at a gym before
I started doing mixed martial arts,
I was doing yoga class and I was
trying to like do it and his leg,
like,
you're just too big.
She only told me that.
I was like,
you're a terrible instructor.
Like how do you want me to come back?
Like what?
You're just too big.
She's like,
you're just too big.
Your muscles are too big.
It's,
she's told me
I was so devastated.
I,
it's walked out.
I know what to do.
I was like,
this is stupid.
Yeah.
That's ridiculous.
I lost my Mojo after that.
No,
no.
You gotta to get back in there.
I would just think that like for a,
for anyone that's involved in
anything that's as brutal as a MMA,
that yoga is a great sort of balancing
thing for that keeps you flexible,
you know,
keeps your core strong,
does a lot of you,
you've developed like weird strength,
strength and like it,
it helps the joints.
It helps a lot of the connecting
tissues helps stabilize everything.
Yeah.
I believe it puzzle isn't a real go
with your mind and stuff like that.
Sure.
Yeah,
that's right.
I mean,
I don't even know.
I've done it like once or twice.
I get told you in the lady was like
your mom sent me like when I read,
I read about and when I seen him on it,
it looks pretty good.
Yeah.
I looked that post on Instagram that
I've put up last night and I saw it from
um,
what pull this up.
Like this is a from Jujitsu brotherhood.
This a yacht.
It what's up?
Um,
yoga is a martial art
you do against yourself.
How do you say Nick's last name?
Grigori Atus quick,
gory aid this or Gloria is anyway,
real good.
Jujitsu guy.
He was the guy that was in London.
Rio,
right?
Wasn't he?
Sure
use that little fancy Google machine.
I'm pretty sure that's neck.
Uh,
he was the,
in the early London Real,
he did our podcast.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
He did the podcast long time ago.
But that's a great quote that,
that yoga is a martial art
you do against yourself.
How long have you been doing it for?
Real serious for like two years.
Two and a half years.
Before that,
I would do it like once a month
or once every now and then.
But now I do it pretty regularly.
We did a,
the sober October thing.
No booze,
no pot,
15 hot yoga classes a month.
I was fucking with life changing,
man.
Yeah.
I haven't done yoga since.
I really have
it,
but I need to cause I fucking,
I tweaked my back
yesterday doing something.
Joe copywriter.
No,
no.
Yeah.
I don't believe in them.
Really?
Don't.
I don't know.
I'm sure you do.
So good.
I think massage is good,
but if you,
did you know how chiropractic was founded?
Do you know where it came from?
Came from a scam artist.
That guy was a magnetic healer and a,
it came to him in a seance that he could
cure all ailments if you manipulate
people's spines.
Yeah.
And then he was killed
by his own son who then,
who was also a scam artist.
His own son ran over him with a fucking
car and they took over the business.
I'm so,
yes,
you know,
people claim all sorts of
benefits for all sorts of things,
but there's no scientific evidence that
manipulating your spine does anything.
The only thing that it does show is
that if you can manipulate lower backs,
sometimes with some people you
can relieve some of the pain.
But I think a lot of that
is just massaging them.
Like a lot of that is
just manipulating them,
just he's just rubbing into them,
giving them some sort of
relief and adjusting them.
But the neck is very dangerous.
You know,
like people want to get their
neck adjusted and feel that pop.
It feels good.
Right.
But literally people have
gotten strokes from that.
Oh yeah.
Well I,
uh,
I just,
I read a study on it and said like,
you know,
they did like,
adjusting,
you know,
twice a week and a kid's like reaction I
in sports right quicker just because of
the,
everything was like lined up perfectly.
Yeah.
I don't think that's real.
I feel like it is that,
I'm sure you do.
I'm just sure.
I just don't think that you,
I don't think your body has
been manipulated that way.
I think that what's happening is
you're putting attention on your body.
You thinking about recovery more,
you're getting adjusted and
while you're getting adjusted,
getting massage.
Yeah,
like when I used to get adjusted,
the best part of it was what you said,
the massage.
That was the best part.
I get it massaged and then I get
adjusted and it felt good like everything
loosened up but,
but when I talked to guys that are actual
orthopedic surgeons and real doctors
like spinal doctors
and they talk about it,
they're like you're
just making like a pop.
Like it's not,
it's not real like it doesn't your,
your body be so fucked up if like you
could manipulate it one way or another and
that's how you fix things.
It's like that's night fixing things.
Like you got an injury.
It's like there's a whole
bunch of shit going on.
Like if you have some sort of
a muscle pull or a back injury.
I soured on it when I had a bulging disc.
And the reason why was because this
guy was convinced that I didn't have a
bulging disc and I didn't get an Mri and
I was just going to a chiropractor and
he was like pushing down on my head.
I had a in my cervical and my,
my neck,
it was uh,
my hands are going numb from Jujitsu and
this guy was like trying to tell him,
you just keep coming to the car,
you'll get adjusted,
it'll be fine.
And then I finally went to a real doctor
and they gave me an Mri and they were
like,
no,
this is why you're in pain.
Your disc is bulging out and it's pressing
against your nerve and it's called
the Ulnar nerve and that's
why your hand is going numb.
Like we're going to give you spinal
decompression and you should try to look
into some things that are
going to reduce inflammation.
They changed my diet and um,
I started,
uh,
getting called Regena cane,
which is like platelet rich
plasma where they take your blood,
they spin it to heat it up.
And in the heating up the blood,
it produces this radical anti inflammatory
process and they then inject that
your own blood back into the injuries
and just fixed it over like a period of
like two or three months.
Then I got another Mri and it went away.
So I think a lot of that
shit is just fucking Voodoo.
It's just nonsense and you think it's
working or you you you're thinking about
it or you're giving yourself time to
rest while you're getting all those
adjustments.
So you think that the
adjustments are what's doing it.
But obviously there's a lot of people
that are chiropractors that are very
skillful in all sorts of
different methods of recovery,
like electrical,
muscular stimulation,
massage as a bunch of different
things and attraction.
I don't know enough about acupuncture.
I always,
I never got it down and I read,
he's like,
eh.
It seems to me like Horse Shit.
If I had a guest it just,
but I don't know.
I mean maybe there's some method to it.
I mean I think that massage works,
that definitely works.
Like,
if I get a good massage and I have like
something that's tight and you know,
I'll look your neck as fucked up from
not tapping or something like that.
And then you go get it massaged out.
Like you can fix that.
Like that actually can
provide you some relief.
Um,
and I'm sure that if you go to a good one
of those people that does the cupping,
like people apparently swear by that Shit,
you know,
you know cup it is covering by the way,
I seen it like,
like socks on the bag and he's like,
it's terrible marks in your body.
But I think that's half of it.
Half of it is like the marks and your
body make you think like you're getting
something done but they take
this cup and it sucks all your,
your skin up into the cup.
And how does that,
I don't know how it works.
Like look at this asshole that guy looks
like he has the worst disease known to
man.
I can manage if that was just
like what happened to your skin?
You got to like some porcupine disease.
It a nipple.
Yeah.
I guess like they have a vacuum thing
and it attaches to the top and it polls.
How is that like,
yeah.
Olympic cupping.
A practice rooted in ancient Islam.
Oh Shit.
Hmm.
Interesting.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
these fucking people are world class
athletes at the top of their game is
cupping there.
Okay.
How about Google does cupping work is
cupping therapy where it's probably
probably some weird sexual
shit called cupping to,
I gotta be real careful when you pull up.
How does cupping work?
Hmm.
Dry Cupping.
Yeah.
How does it work?
The Glass Cup is warmed by burning and
alcohol soaked cotton ball inside of it
and they're making a bomb.
Uh,
this,
this removes the oxygen in the cup,
which creates a vacuum.
The Cup is turned upside down
and placed on the patient's back.
The vacuum created by the lack of oxygen.
Oh,
that's this kind of cupping.
But the other one seemed to have
like a stem on the top of it.
We're a vacuum thing pulls in,
but what is it supposed to do?
Facts down here it says,
how do you feel about ice now
thing that's very important.
Yeah.
Drawing up the skin.
Go scroll over towards the rights.
I can see the year drawing up the skin
and the cop is believed to open the
skin's pores,
which helps to stimulate the blood
flow balances and realigns the flow.
Okay,
you fucked me with this,
this ci Q I Ballot
realigns the flow of Qa.
Oh,
you got any?
You got any peer reviewed
studies on that Qa.
You fucking dipshit.
Breaking up obstructions creates an
avenue for toxins to be drawn out of the
body again,
as soon as ass all start
talking about toxins,
oh,
well,
I'm just cleansing.
I'm on a deep cleanse,
getting the toxins out of my body.
It's just bullshit talk.
That whole toxins talk is,
I'm pulling toxins out of my body.
The fuck you are.
No.
You know,
it pulls toxins out of your body.
Your liver,
you dump cunt.
That's what,
that's what your livers for.
It gets the toxins out.
You're not pulling them out with a cup.
For me,
it's a sauna.
After I've been drinking all day sweat.
Yeah,
your sweat does Lisa,
a little fat filter
out some of that water,
that ionic foot spa thing.
Oh,
that's the worst where the the your foot,
the water turns black and they try to
pretend that it's like toxins coming out
of you.
But meanwhile it's just a reaction.
It's a chemical reaction.
Yeah.
You ever seen that?
They,
they,
they have this thing,
it's plugged in and your,
your foot sits in it and there's some
sort of reaction with the water and your
feet.
It turns black and they try to tell you,
oh,
the toxins and coming out of your
body and then you walk out of there.
I feel amazing.
No,
I need a colonic.
no.
This is not real.
Ladies and gentlemen.
What is that like?
What are they doing?
What is the exact reaction?
There's lots of videos you can look up
where people would do the exact process
with ad.
Not without putting anything in there.
Yeah.
And the water is still turns black.
And I think it's something to
do with like battery acid or,
I don't know.
Honestly,
that might not be it,
but it's something weird.
It's bullshit.
See,
people want to get healed.
You get hurt,
you want to get healed.
You want to believe anything.
Well,
you ever heard of Reiki healers?
No,
they didn't.
that's a,
that's Raul thing.
That's real.
That's legit.
That's like Sasha manipulation.
Reiki is like they rubbed their hands
and they just pass him over your body and
they heal you.
We have this one video
that we were watching this,
this one lady was just rubbing
her hand above this lady's Vagina.
Just like above it.
Like what is going on there?
You're trying to,
who kind of sorcery are
you using when you try to,
what are you trying to
exercise from this lady's body?
Yeah.
And next thing you know,
she's the number one
porno star in America.
I look and I did it with my hands,
my healing,
my Reiki,
healing.
I met a dude last night.
There was a psychic healer told
me it was a psychic healer.
I go,
good luck with that.
That's not real.
You fuck psychic healer.
The reason I asked about icing cause like
I know there's some people that don't
like icing.
They like doing that like that.
It's like the drink gets
hurt unless it's needed,
but like,
you know,
see you sprain your ankle and you can't
just start moving right away and get
blood flow back in there without,
yeah.
There's,
there's some evidence that um,
well I think it depends
entirely upon the injury,
but if you look at the vast majority
of scientists and sports medicine
therapists and the people that are
at the cutting edge of the business,
they almost all use eyes.
Yeah.
They don't think that you,
you're not supposed to use ice,
um,
within,
what was it?
Who was it on the podcast?
Was it a Andy Galpin?
Who was it that was talking about the,
about the timeframe between icing
and exercise where you need to,
or it might've been Rhonda Patrick.
There's a beneficial amount of time
you should wait before you ice after an
exercise like that.
You,
you give yourself a chance for
more recovery and more growth.
If you wait a while before icing,
like save,
you had a hard training session,
you wouldn't want to go
right to cryotherapy.
You might want to wait an hour and a half,
two hours and then go and then you'll
get the benefits of the hard training.
But then you also get the
anti-inflammatory benefits of Cryo.
Yeah,
when I get crown at first time,
a couple of times to do it and I was like,
this
sucks.
Like I wasted a bunch of money.
Like this is like,
I just hated it.
Right.
This is the only place.
Plus also it's free,
which is nice.
That's really nice.
Yeah.
Right.
And the guy's like,
hey man,
you know,
to come out.
So I checked out and like,
man,
I got done with that one.
It was like I felt the coldness
coming like in my whole body.
And so it was a better place
you into a better place?
I think so.
I think it works cause I
definitely feel a difference.
You know?
How long you in town for her?
I'm leaving tomorrow.
Tim,
I want to take you to a place out here,
cryotherapy,
cryo healthcare out here.
They have a very unique system.
Their system is,
it's first of all the
guys that developed it,
what they did was instead of having it
while you're breathing in lik liquid
nitrogen,
you know like where it's from,
the neck down,
which is a lot of those places.
You go into it and you're breathing air
and you have to have your head above
where the Cryo is because you can't breed
that shit in which is how that girl in
Vegas died.
Folks,
if you don't know,
there's a girl in Vegas,
they went in the tank by herself and she
was too short and she was breathing in
the nitrogen and she passed out
and then she froze to death.
But the ones that cryo healthcare,
that's the normal one.
That's like Floyd Mayweather in there,
right there where you see the,
the,
the cryo stuff is all below his head.
The ones that Cryo healthcare,
they jack the temperature way
down like 240 degrees below zero.
And one of what they do is
they freeze the air itself.
So the air they're pumping
into his super cold air.
So you go in there with full,
like you're,
you're,
you're breathing in this cold air.
It's on your head.
Your full body is immersed in this,
this cold air.
So it's a,
it's way more intense and it's supposed
to have way more benefit because your
head gets cold too.
So the reaction that your body
has for producing sidechains and
anti-inflammatory,
cold shock proteins,
your body freaks out way more
when everything is covered.
Not just the neck down,
but your
head too.
Yeah.
So too,
I wish you were in town.
I'll take you there.
Yeah,
that's pretty sweet.
We gotta do this.
You've got some other duties.
Yeah,
I do.
What do you have to do
other UFC stuff now?
Not even your,
yeah,
kind of,
Nah,
I was like,
my stuff,
I don't know.
I didn't want to go,
but I had to go like a big kid.
Oh,
it's my wife's like just go and I,
I put below,
fine.
That's funny right now.
And just training when
you have a big fight,
how much of the big fight is like how
much of the pain in the ass it's doing
press?
I want to say you're complaining about it,
but I mean it's as far
as like time constraints.
Sometimes it sucks.
It does suck cause like you
and you're sitting in a year,
you're thinking about
doing this in the car.
Like hey,
you're like,
oh right.
You know,
but I understand it's part of the game.
It helps you know,
promote you and you know,
your sales and you know,
paper views,
all that stuff like this.
But there's like a balance to be achieved.
Right.
Those kind of Greg argument,
Conor Mcgregor's argument was whether
when he went on that world tour with Aldo,
he's like,
they just did way too much.
He's like,
by the time you're doing all this,
you don't have time to train.
He goes,
there's no way you're going to train,
recover,
sleep correctly.
You're flying from one
city to another country,
to another country and you're
just constantly on a jet.
I was like,
I mean,
yeah,
when we went to Australia,
I mean I'm flew,
I'll share my five Mark Hunt and uh,
I remember I flew more than it actually
was there in Australia while I was there
for like a day and a half
and I flew back home.
That's crazy.
It was bad.
So the flight is more,
more time.
I think it was,
it was like a 20 hour flight
there in 24 and 20 hours
of Dicks.
That flight is,
you get out of there and
you're just half a person,
you look confused and like something
happens to you when you fly in 1617 hours
in a plane.
I was there for after the flat.
So I got there a week
early before the flight.
I stayed for the week of the flight and
I was there like three or four more days
later.
So I was the one who was there with three,
three and a half,
two and a half,
23 weeks.
And I got home and I literally,
it was crazy.
So I get home at like seven in the
morning and my brothers in my house,
my wife from your wife
come home and I'm like,
I'm tracking my eyes open
and like it was like my,
I was like so miss combobulated
so I'd get in the car.
I almost forgot how to drive because
I was on the other side of it was my
brother.
I'm like,
you should probably drive.
He's the way I like cause I have not
been on the side of the road in a long
time.
What you drive it in Australia?
No,
no it was just,
I was seeing they,
I was just saying that happens inside.
It was just so weird,
you know,
just everything was so
awkward and immune was Craig.
We went,
I went for a run and they're freaking
parrots and like Kangaroos and shit dude.
Like just regular like it's
like our seagulls and crows.
I'm like running right
cause like rainbows,
like two can't stand next to me.
Yeah,
Australia is a weird place,
man.
Yeah it was,
it was crazy.
But like my time clock was screwed up.
I went to work a couple a couple of days
later and like I was still like four
days later and I was still like messed up.
It was bad.
Yeah.
I could fuck you up for a week or two,
but you know,
it's worth it just to
go to Australia to see.
Amazing.
It's a great place.
Yeah.
Once your family,
when you have a big fight
with a guy like say mark,
how
well you know,
could be a brawl and that turned
out to be a five round fight.
Right.
Was it a fair four and a half?
Yeah.
He stopped him in the fifth.
Yep.
Um,
when you,
you have a fight like that and you know,
this is,
you're in there for the long haul.
Do you plan on like staying for
days after the fight to recover?
No.
I actually wanted to get home,
but I had,
I was the bad boy,
so he wanted me to do a couple
like promotional thing down here.
They play,
they get to see my family.
So I have family other
than Melbourne and Sydney.
Oh,
you have family out there.
Oh no kidding.
Yeah.
So we hung out there for a little bit.
It was cool.
Did you see that video that
they posted a yesterday of a,
these guys in Australia with a 39 foot
boat and a shark swam by those 20 feet
long?
You see that video?
It's a fucking insane video cause the
shark is almost as big as the God damn
boat.
They have this 39 foot boat
and they have an overhead,
like a drone footage of the sharks
swimming around the boat and they're like
cheeses.
I definitely shit my pants.
And that one was not much you can do.
I mean,
you don't have a whole lot of options.
yeah.
Wow.
It's like 20 foot shark.
That's crazy.
Fuck all that.
And that was truly has a ton of those.
They're all over the place.
Yeah,
I mean I,
I was talking,
math happens a lot apparently.
Right?
18 foot shark next to a 21 foot boat.
Fuck that dude.
Oh my God.
Videos like those whales
and stuff that I brought up.
You know,
like right next to the bone.
Yeah.
What does this one Jamie,
18 foot shirt next to the 21 foot boat.
Oh my God.
That thing is big.
Jesus Christ.
Huge.
And it's just swimming
next to the boat going,
can I eat you?
Hmm?
How do I eat you?
Hmm.
Not sure if I can eat you.
God Damn Kid.
Get back.
Get back and it was your son.
You little fuck.
Sit down.
Jesus Christ.
It's a shark.
Yeah,
there,
there.
Did you see the video of the guy was
diving the real recent video and they like
hit the back of the shock,
came over and thumped
the back of his head.
He just,
that one guy who was our fishing.
Nah,
he was like,
oh it was probably
thinking of other video,
but he's like this,
you know old guys like this and that
and the seat and he's like this and the
swordfish.
Half of it.
Go do it.
The holding jumped in.
Oh what was it started going crazy?
The one guy,
he jumped overboard cause he's like,
you didn't want get like
sauteed by this thing.
You know,
guys know though.
She's like,
I tried to like get out of the chair.
I tried to hurry it up.
You know,
it was great.
Fish is trying to get away from a shark.
Is that what I think you
should just flew his jumped in.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I saw like that,
like the seal one time was like,
you jumped in the boat was
trying to wait from my guy.
I kill a whale.
Yeah.
To My,
my oldest daughter when she was 13,
we went fishing and she was
a vegetarian at the time.
She loves animals.
And uh,
and I was like,
but she was eating fish.
I said,
listen,
let's just go fishing.
We'll catch a fish,
we'll cook it.
And you'll get like this sort
of connection with your food.
Is this,
what was this one?
She's in south beach the other day.
Some guy just shortly,
10 feet the coast.
This guys just trying to die.
What is he doing?
Because I don't know if he even saw it.
So anyway,
um,
I'm on this boat and we
catch a Marlin within
10 minutes of the,
the trip,
10 minutes in,
we catch a Marlin,
which is crazy,
right?
All of a sudden
I'm pulling this thing in
and it's not a big Marlin.
It's probably like 80 pounds
or something like that.
We get it into the boat and they beat
the fucking thing to death with clubs
right in front of her.
Cause that's what they do.
They pull it in and
then just fucking thump,
thump,
thump.
And she's sitting there,
Ooh.
And then they put it on ice after that.
And then when they put it on ice,
it's like still alive.
Every now and then he'd
hear like its tail.
It'd be flapping out,
it'd be spasming.
It would come back to life and
they sub it in the head again.
She was a vegetarian for another
year after that took a while.
It took a while to turn it back around.
My thought was like,
we're going to go catch some Mahi Mahi.
This is going to be great Marlin,
you usually don't catch a Marlin.
And we caught one within 10 minutes.
Yeah,
it was,
uh,
I mean,
yeah,
like you were going to be a good dad.
You know,
like they're just
smash the smile.
It's just was the total wrong experience.
Like my youngest daughter's,
I took them fishing and they caught
little fish and it was a great experience.
It was like what I was hoping for,
like the caught little fish.
We brought it back to the restaurant.
The restaurant cooked him.
You were staying at a
resort and that was great.
I was like,
Woo,
nobody got club.
I was terrified the
first time I took them.
I'm like,
if you're fucking four and you watch
a Marlin and get clubbed today,
might not ever bounce back from that.
I remember I would do if I,
if I,
if I was a child and saw that
I probably be scarred for life.
I fucked up.
I didn't,
I just didn't.
I just,
the only time I've ever
caught a Marlin to I've,
I've gotten ocean fish and a hundred
times they won't cut a Marlin.
I've never been Osha fishing.
Oh,
it's the best.
Yeah,
man.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
The only thing that that's kind of a
bummer was a lot of times they just want a
troll.
Right?
So they're just pulling
the lines behind the boats.
You're not really actively doing anything.
I like casting,
you know,
like the best a ocean fishing
I've done is in Mexico for,
um,
I think there are either skipjack or
amberjack tune and I forget what they're
called,
but we would go and there would be a,
they would follow these
seagulls and bait fish.
So like the bait fish should be frothing
on the water cause the tuna were
underneath jacket him and then
just cast into them and just,
Oh,
it was amazing.
We're in Mexico.
Uh,
it was outside of Cabo,
so it's like,
uh,
no,
it was outside Puerto by.
Yeah,
it was outside Puerto Bayada so I'm not
sure like what part of the ocean it was,
but it's great.
You know,
it's not when you eat a fish
that you caught like an hour ago,
you realize like,
wow,
this tastes way better.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
Like what happened?
The degrading of the,
it's the kind of the opposite
meat because with meat,
like you can eat a lot of meat fresh right
after he kill it and it tastes really
good,
but much,
much of like,
like the best cuts of meat that you
get like from a butcher or form a,
a,
a really good steak restaurant.
They let it age now they let an,
apparently they do that with tuna too.
Like when you get Sushi.
I didn't know that.
Yeah,
they let that Shit Age.
I love Sushi.
Do you fish?
Ah,
I mean I used to like back in the day.
Yeah.
I,
how do you have time,
right?
Yeah.
I'm kind of busy.
I have a little pot in my house,
but I don't think have a pond.
Yeah,
it's not huge.
Probably 20 yards by 20 yards.
Not Big at all.
But we do have the massive turtles,
like,
like the one that bond.
I had no idea.
So I actually,
we made a bet,
one of the UFC fights and budget.
My coaches were over and I was lit up
having fun in the work and I never bet.
And they're like,
hi,
bridging.
This person went.
And so I was like,
I'll take that back.
Like w w w what happens
in you when I'm like,
if you,
if the person that wins,
you know you can do
everyone to pick whatever,
you know.
So I went,
oh my God,
you gotta have to get in them getting a
little shuttle boat and had to do across
the lake and we did snow balls at you.
It was never winter.
And they're like,
no,
I'm like a hundred percent
you're going to do it.
So the best part was,
it was heavy,
it was covered in ice.
So they can go anywhere and put pedicle.
It's sucks.
So they're just sitting
and I'm just really numb,
so whatever.
And we'll do our thing in Austin.
Like months later,
my wife's like,
honey,
she sends me a video of these,
these massive snapping turtles.
They're like hate fucking each other.
Like really the ones I sent,
I want,
if I can find it on the phone,
the ones like this and I'll get some bags.
And I was thinking,
I was like,
I tried to like brace face off.
I'm like,
what the Hell is going on?
It was like,
but they were like,
I mean I could,
you know,
they had both that doing
that big there are massive.
And then I looked over and they had
like a bunch of babies and they don't,
and then an extra so long
I get the grab and by like,
by the behind the,
cause they'll bite your hand off.
Yeah.
So those uh,
just moved into your neighborhood?
Is that what happened?
It was there where I live.
Like it's weird.
So I have like a private
drive from my house.
You can't see my house off the driveway.
So we have like a little pond.
And so yeah.
But were they there before?
They're always been there.
They go back and forth in
a little pond next to it.
That connected where
our drivers cook 'em up.
Turtle soup recipe,
half decent if you cook it right.
What is your diet like?
You know,
usual pizza,
beer.
I frowned upon that.
I mean,
I joked around about that,
but we had Courtney [inaudible],
she's a woman who won
the Moab to 40 oh Yay.
Check is a fucking savage.
She beat every man,
every person who entered that
race by a marathon length,
240 miles and she was,
she was ahead by more than 20 miles.
The next person,
the second place person was more than
20 miles behind her when she won.
So he's just like an ultra marathon.
Yeah,
yeah.
To three days for some people.
But for her,
she did it and I think she did it in too.
Right?
Cause she,
she's an animal.
She's a fucking animal.
Anyway,
beer,
Nachos,
candy.
That's what she eats.
Beer and Nachos and,
and we were like,
what?
Like I expected some sophisticated
Kenogenic diet protocol where they're
monitoring or fucking or ketone
levels in her blood and checking out.
All of our portions are mapped out.
Rago running around.
When she was here,
she just kept eating candy.
She was just eating candy
like m and m's and shit.
She said,
I mean,
I kind of meals.
Yeah,
those are great.
You get a meal prep?
Yeah,
definitely send me a bunch of stuff.
It's good.
Um,
yeah,
but I am going to have you
wait so long or you know.
Right.
You know,
on some days a lot pizza.
You can do whatever the fuck you want,
but I don't like,
have you ever thought about
trying to go to two oh five
we thought about it,
but I'd be really tough.
What do you weigh now?
To 40 yeah.
And you're not fat,
so what you like,
even if you got super lean,
you're probably looking at two 25 and
then a hard cut to 25 classes all day.
Yeah.
Easy mate.
That I think there should be one.
Me Too.
I think there should be a
lot more weight classes.
I really do.
And I know there's a resistance because
they want to keep the spore pure.
They don't want it.
Like boxing was a weight
class every four pounds.
But I feel like if you look at guys,
there's a lot of guys
that I think are tweeners,
you know,
they're like,
they're not quite,
yeah,
well you're a heavyweight.
You can't say you're a trainer,
but you can't see the champ.
But this guys that,
you know,
like Diego Sanchez was
always a good example.
He's a little bit too small to make 55
when he tried to make 45 was a disaster
like,
but if there was a 65 pound weight class,
I think that's perfect for him.
And there's a lot of guys that
like 70 to 85 that's a big jump.
85 to two oh five that's crazy.
That's 20 pounds.
Yeah,
I mean I think definitely
a few more weight classes.
Not like,
yeah,
every 10 pounds.
Yeah,
I think I'd be great too.
I think I'd be on board for that.
Um,
I think that's the move every 10 pounds.
And then when you go to o five
two oh five to two 25 to 25 to,
it should be unlimited.
It shouldn't be to 65.
I know that seems silly to me,
but I think that two of those
guys that are unlimited that that,
that they won't last long,
they might not put in Ghana was cutting
weight to get to two 65 way to 50 last
Friday I thought.
No,
no he weighed two 62 63 to
63 or [inaudible] 64 yeah,
no he's cutting weight.
Oh cool.
Yeah.
I'm a big fellow but obviously
there's pros and cons to being big.
And the con is that if you're
getting into the third,
fourth and fifth rounds,
yeah.
You know those big guys are
not known for their endurance.
Did they say that the weight class,
like there's like there was
always a thought in MMA,
like when Cain Velasquez was on top,
there was a thought that that
might be the perfect size,
like two 40 like anything
bigger than that,
maybe it's just like not worth it.
Cause a 240 pound man cause basically
knock out anybody on the planet.
And so the power is still there.
But you have more like nobody
had more endurance and cane.
No,
no.
I think.
I think so.
I think being at two 48
you just throw it out.
The curt here,
it's sort of the strengths or the speed.
I mean that's why I love be where I'm at.
You know?
I don't
try again.
I mean I'm not going to trust you more
than you ever thought about gaining or
no,
no.
I mean I've,
I've I've gained,
I remember why after mark on man I w I
kind of went off the deep end and just
went on a binge drinking and finally
me waiting for like living in an but of
life and I show,
I stepped on the scale.
It's like,
what'd you want to 59 wow.
I never weighed in my life.
Do you take a picture
like holding your gut?
No,
I didn't actually.
I looked exactly the same.
I know that I just looked
like a little bit thicker.
Nothing like bad though.
So it filled out good.
Yeah,
it was a good,
yeah,
I think a lot of him in the ass too.
So if you're a chick,
it would have been a good move.
Yeah,
I would have been working all day.
Don't totally rambled back to
the whole ultra marathon thing.
So I'm a Weirdo.
And so I found out about
watching marathons.
So I go on Wikipedia and I
started reading all about it.
They were talking about,
and then I really like the top three guys.
Like they're crazy.
Like the one guy was like the first ever.
My argument of the guy like
that did awesome was it's,
I can't a little runner kettle
like guy cattle farmer guy,
cattle farmer.
They run through the night.
Well he didn't sleep at night so
he would just run and keep on it.
She didn't run fast but his feet.
But then they had another
guy who I saw that guy,
I saw a video about that guy.
And then,
yeah.
And then there was another guy,
he uh,
he was like third years old here,
like epiphany.
He was like,
he was drinking one night and he just
got sick or like he just wants to drink
when I first birthday party,
put on my shoes and just start running.
Realized yet,
you know,
you can still run.
And he like tore it up again.
I don't know who the guy's name was.
He like American and another guy,
he was like,
at one point he was sleeping and running
and like he's still like while he was
sleeping he was running.
Yeah.
He was like,
yeah,
I can't talk.
Give me a break.
But he's like,
but he's like that.
They laid,
watched him sleep.
I was running,
I use like,
Whoa,
I don't remember him.
The guy,
he's like twins Doring no,
no what I'm saying,
what I'm saying,
he was just running,
just,
I don't know if you're snoring,
but like they had another time,
like they were saying a story about it.
He like twist his ankle and beginning
of the race and it was a good size of a
grapefruit.
He still destroyed everyone.
We did the fish.
Like I fight everyone in
the cross finish line.
Wow.
It's got about in there and look it up.
And he was like,
I dunno.
It's like,
did you find this cliff young shuffle?
Yeah,
that's the,
yeah,
that's the cattle rancher guy.
So he,
he does,
he kind of has a shuffle.
And the idea was that that shuffle allowed
him to save energy because he wasn't
a,
it wasn't like picking up
his legs like really high.
He's just kind of like shuffling along.
Yeah,
I remember this guy.
Yeah.
Look at him.
He competed without his false teeth
because they rattled when he ran Jesus
Christ
when they showed up and no one
thought it was nobody was doing,
they didn't know what he did if he
didn't knew what he signed up for.
Wow.
I mean,
well he won.
Well,
the history is filled with guys like that.
It's like everybody thinks they know
exactly how everything works until someone
comes along.
That's a completely unique version
that no one had seen before.
Like that guy doing this little shuffle.
It's amazing.
Or like this Courtney go.walter Chick,
she,
she won.
She
has beat the world record for the most
amount of hours a woman has ever run in
24 hours.
She's a freak.
And again,
candy drink,
a beer.
Nachos.
I think watching this people,
I run marathons like it's crazy.
Remember one year I have my one coach,
he did like security detail for
like the Cleveland Refco Marathon.
So I'm like,
I sat there,
it was a worst day of my life though.
I literally sat by ended than driving
five miles power behind people running,
so they like fell off.
I'd pick him up,
take him to the finish line,
but it was just crazy why she'd be like,
there was so like,
like nuts.
I'm another one guy,
we stopped the checkout him.
He's like saying like,
ah right,
you're right again.
And,
and stuff like that.
He's like,
yeah,
I'll be fine.
He put IBM,
he went to go finish the race,
right.
And this guy is like dead on west,
gets ivy,
comes back to life.
He's like,
I got this cozy get started running again
and I'll never forget we're brought to
be done.
And I see the guy running,
he's about a hundred yards away and
he starts like tripping and falling.
He couldn't finish the race.
Wow.
Hundred yards away.
And he's like lily a hundred yards away.
He couldn't have,
he couldn't finish it,
but I was like,
oh,
I felt so bad.
He was like,
lily about the thought
pass out of the first time.
They put an Ivy felt great.
He's like,
I'm good.
Leave me alone.
Took off again.
And then it's an endurance.
Racing is a totally
different kind of thing.
As far as like the mindset,
like if you think about a
five round heavyweight title,
fight is a grueling affair,
right?
It's 25 minutes of throwing bones
at the best fighters in the world,
but it's still 25 minutes.
These mother fuckers like this,
Courtney do alter chick.
She's running for three days.
It's crazy.
What does it as a Dallas Marathon,
this was the lady that was winning.
She uh,
got to the end and she
just collapsed in this,
this girl helped her.
She's like a high schooler.
She was running one of the shorter
races and just saw her and just like,
I was compelled to help her.
Wow.
Do you still won the race?
She's,
yes,
she was.
I guess the lady said she was afraid she
was going to get disqualified because
someone was helping her,
but they still,
she still won.
Oh,
it is.
We get at check some of that
money so someone's helping her.
That seems weird.
Sort of helping or you can
kind of tell she doesn't really
picking her up though.
She's picking her up every time she falls.
I feel like that's cheating.
They might've had some rules.
I don't listen.
Hey.
Hey,
what about the rules?
And people will tell that
bitch she get back or metal.
No,
just kidding.
Just kidding.
Who himself was legal?
They said in fights.
Now if you pooped yourself,
they stopped the fight.
A lot of guys up shit themselves.
A lot of guys famously.
Yeah,
I mean,
let the rest of the gang card.
One time that shows pants.
I remember Michael [inaudible],
who was he fighting?
A Bonil Dariusz and right.
We're right before the fight started.
He leans over to the cage.
He goes,
dude,
he goes,
I might shit myself during the fight.
I go,
you serious?
And he's like,
I got shit so bad.
Are you serious?
And he wound up choking out there.
You should thank God.
And we were talking about it afterwards.
He goes,
Bro,
he goes something.
What happened during the fight?
It went away,
but I was convinced I
was going to shit myself.
He goes,
I just got out there and I was like,
oh no,
that's the worst feeling I have
the table feeling that'd be like,
or I'll ski like from my
hotel room.
They're coming to get me.
And I'm like,
you know what I mean,
just shit.
Make sure thank God I Shit.
Cause wherever came out of me like
it was like just discussing diarrhea.
I'm,
I said,
all right,
I'll get down on my
imagine we'll fill that in.
Oh yeah.
I didn't feel like I
had to go by the yellow.
Just checked me on the safe side.
No Man,
thank God I fucking,
that was a big win for you to,
we just started it all.
Yeah,
it was a big one cause
it was like a definitive,
it was like you were marching towards
a title and then when you blast it or
Lawsky out there's like,
all right,
this guy's the guy that
does the next Guy Mo.
It took a little alarm map.
Yeah.
But I mean,
you know what I'm saying?
Like that was the definitive
like where you're like,
I want my fucking shot.
Like where's my fucking shit?
Like right then and there,
like that was sort of one of those
moments where like he got to give this guy
the shot.
Yeah.
No,
I appreciate it.
You helped me out with that too.
I appreciate that.
You know a big fan now.
I appreciate it.
In the title fight man.
Holy Shit.
That must've been amazing.
Knocking out for doom in Brazil like
that with one punch and the Holy Shit.
That was like one of the best title
fight winning performances ever.
Yeah,
it was a good night.
Yeah.
I wish to work on that a lot.
Step over and Red Cross and the
guy chasing you down just dangling,
you know.
And you know,
it's just,
uh,
it was just,
what a great night.
You know,
I just,
I wouldn't be there without
my coaches honestly.
They're just great people.
Of course there's just this one reason
there just cause they put so much time
and effort into me.
I got to say it over and over again.
But they're just amazing guys and I'm
very lucky to have them in my corner.
Well,
they're very lucky to have you to,
you know,
it takes both,
and you're right.
You know,
you have a great relationship
with your coaches too,
which is very important I think.
Like,
like you were saying
about having a great wife,
having great friends,
having a great support system,
like all that stuff.
Like for your mind,
for your mindset,
it's great.
But having coaches that you have a
great relationship with that you really,
you know,
they're looking out for you,
they're working hard for you
guys are in there together.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's what I love about
my head coach Marcus.
I looked at him like a long time ago.
I was like,
man,
what is wage retired today?
He's like,
more time to drink wine,
bro.
That's what I love about it.
Fine.
Yeah.
He's like,
I don't care dude.
You can do what you want.
I just drove around and
see what he would say.
You know?
He was like,
Bro,
he's like whatever.
He was like,
I listened to,
I just mind you be happy.
You know?
That's the best kind of coach man.
That's the best kind of coach that way
when you were talking in the worst is the
kind of coach that wants to go to fight.
When you really know it's over,
you know,
and the guy really should be
stepping away and then you see them,
you know,
trying to give the guy
the pep talk and you know,
the best days are in the past.
That's why mark is
actually real good at that.
You know,
we've got a couple of guys that were like,
I want to get down.
He's like,
he's like,
yeah,
and you'd be in your corner.
He's like,
no,
she retire.
Yeah.
I mean he was,
he really killed them
inside to tell him that.
But he's like,
listen,
you know,
you know what,
this is an important point to talk,
but you remember that feeling that
you felt like after this true fight,
it's like you've got to kind of figure
that out on your own and come back on
your own.
Right.
And some guys,
they have that feeling
and then they're never,
they're set those same again.
They never reached those same like you
got better for sure you rose above that.
But some people are dwarfed
by bad performances or a
bad knock out or whatever
it is.
And they just never,
they never the same again.
Yeah.
I mean I just,
I think it's,
you know,
there's two types.
People are either going to be
going above and beyond it or not.
I mean,
that's just how it is.
But there's also stages in your life too,
right,
where you just don't
want to do it anymore.
Like you see some guys
who at one point in time,
great driven fighters and then
the grind just gets to them.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
I told understanding like,
I mean,
I was just talking to her.
They're talking about this volante.
Yeah.
It seems less,
I mean,
I've had 11 UFC fights,
I think more than level of
Lowe's or been five rounder.
I would train for five hours.
That's insane.
Yeah.
My third,
my fourth UFC fire was a five rounder.
Did.
Even if they didn't go five rounds,
you're still doing training for fire.
Yeah.
You're doing a camp for five rounds.
I mean,
yeah.
Ever since diff,
a dune fight was so crazy because I almost
think you benefited from it being in
Brazil because it seemed like
for doom was so emotional.
It's so ramped up
because it was in Brazil.
He's like chase and after you,
which I was like,
this is crazy.
Yeah.
I think a little bit too is that,
you know,
we knew exactly what was going to do and
she did and everything he wanted to do
and I just wasn't falling for
anything you wanted for a flying knee.
You went for a take down,
you want it for a body kick.
I just wasn't giving
me anything you wanted,
you know,
I don't think you realize
that it wasn't going anywhere.
You also caught him before
that big punch to yeah,
when we watched the fight we did a fight
can pan and we've watched the fight.
You clipped him early and I was like,
he's hurt.
You could tell there
was something going on.
Like when he got hit,
like,
and then he tried to get it back and you
know when a guy gets hit and then just
try extra hard to get it back.
Like a lot of times they're exposed
and he just caught that right hand.
Perfect.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I heard it wouldn't be here right now.
What was that feeling like?
Man?
Awesome.
Like,
so when I hit him to any phone,
I was like,
Oh shit.
He fell because I was the last time
he's been knocked out like that.
Right.
He was out like junior was
the last real early on.
I was like,
he's on a tear.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
So I gave me a couple extra one.
Right.
And then,
you know,
um,
I stopped the fight and I was,
I looked at her,
I saw my coach was like,
Oh hell yeah.
Yeah,
run over.
And I was like,
you know,
like no one heard it before that.
But before I said,
I'm a world champ,
I looked at my coach and like,
we did it.
We did it,
you know,
that's what I told him I was,
we all did it,
you know,
that's,
I'm a world champ and that kind of like
Fred Tanke I blacked out and to remember
what I said that to her,
but I,
you know,
it was a,
it was just,
it was awkward too because
it was so quiet in there.
Not here was myself screaming.
Oh,
it was amazing.
It was amazing.
We were clapping when,
when you were,
when you hopped over the,
the octagon and you're standing there,
you're like,
I'm a world champ,
I'm the world champ.
You're like,
it was like setting in
like you could see it,
those moments,
man,
those are some of my all time favorite
moments when a guy realizes is like the
biggest dream,
the biggest accomplishment
of his career thus far,
at least in to see a guy
like you win the title.
It's just,
there's nothing like that man.
It's nothing like that.
Yeah,
it really is great.
You know,
you know it's 45,000 we
had about 15 people there,
so 45,000 people rooting for,
for breezy overdue.
My,
she was 44,985 I 15 there for me.
So and then boom.
Yeah,
it was my,
my actually my,
my brother and my cousins and now they're
all the top row with my buddies and
they said when I knocked him out,
they all go into,
yeah,
they're going crazy.
And actually they're like,
oh yeah,
all right,
I'll go down.
I'm like,
what's up bro?
What's up?
They're like,
we're sorry.
it's okay.
You know?
Congratulations.
They weren't really nice about,
you know,
they were there.
Oh,
that's cool.
It must have been silent in there
though when you dropped him.
Oh,
it would deal with it.
Honestly,
it was so awkward.
Like it was so awkward.
Like you're just,
cause I remember sharing
myself screaming like,
am I gay man?
What was the crowd doing?
Nothing.
They're just quiet,
quiet.
It was like,
I am a hermit.
He,
my wife's screaming.
I hear,
I heard her screaming
and that was about it.
Wow.
It was a,
it was awkward and then clean.
It was like a total one 80 you know,
that was crazy too.
I'm sure,
you know,
I'm gonna put on my ass and then getting
up and when the Zombie mode didn't care
after that.
Wow.
It's a crazy time for you.
You know,
you're the UFC heavyweight
champion of the world.
I mean,
one day you're going to
look back and we talk.
Any grandkids you could talking about
the time now and you're the fucking champ
of the world.
No,
that was pretty intense.
Yeah.
I'm excited,
man.
You said something,
you know,
you know what,
be proud of my wife,
my wife,
my mom,
you know,
he's like,
Hey,
you know,
my son actually did
something with his life.
You know what I'm excited about too,
for the,
for you,
for this and gone,
oh fight.
It's just going to be a lot of
people buying this on paper view.
This is going to be a big fight,
you know,
and these big fights,
this is what makes you know,
a champion popular.
I mean,
this is really,
this is,
I mean,
the historically inboxing,
they've always said that the
health of the heavyweight division,
it just represents like boxing overall.
I don't think that's the case
anymore because now I'm boxing.
You got all these lightweight
guys like Gennady,
Golovkin and Canelo Alvarez,
a Loma Chanko,
all these big stars now that are emerging
in a lighter weight divisions just
because they're so skillful and talented.
Andre Ward.
But I think in the
heavyweight division that UFC,
um,
it's been a while since people like
really pumped up about a big heavyweight
title fight.
Yeah.
I'm excited,
man.
He listened.
He's a good,
tough dude,
you know?
I mean,
you bring the pain,
so why?
But,
uh,
fortunately I'm not walking
out without that balance.
I'm still the champ and we were,
and still,
when you see a guy like that,
what preparations,
like what,
what do you think is different about him
than guys you fight before and what are
you going to do different?
Well,
I mean there's,
I mean,
every guy is different.
every fight is different.
You,
you know,
like,
yeah,
everyone's like,
oh my God,
his punching power.
I mean,
listen,
there's a lot of guys,
they had a hard,
I mean,
yeah,
there's,
there's no question and you guys hit hard.
I mean,
but I'm going to knock to be stupid.
Put myself in a position
where I'm going to get hit.
You know,
I'm going to do things that
make him feel uncomfortable and
won't do what I'm going to do.
I'm not going to sit there
and let him do what he wants.
I'm going to dictate what I want.
When you see the rest of
the heavyweight division,
do you see any standouts or any guys
that are coming up that are exciting to
you?
Wow.
Honestly,
I don't pay,
you don't pay attention.
That's,
that's a fascinating thing
because some people deal,
you know,
like I talked to Matt Hughes after and
Matt Hughes got beat by Bj Penn and this
is what he said.
It was really fascinating because he had,
he's got so much courage that guy like
to say to say this in an interview as
well.
He's like,
honestly,
it's a relief.
And he's like,
being the champ was like so much pressure.
It was just,
it's overwhelming.
So having this happen,
honestly,
right now I feel relieved and I was like,
wow,
that's crazy.
Yeah.
It's not like you gave up
and he fought his heart out,
but he got caught and got choked out.
And then to go from that to say,
you know,
honestly,
he's really then rebounds,
then gets back on the horse and you know,
probably had to have that experience
just to have the perspective that more,
I don't know if he ever had
the perspective that you have,
but your perspective is
different in that you like,
you don't seem to be concerned.
Well,
I mean I'm concerned.
There's no question.
I think every Friday,
you know,
I'm nervous,
I'm always never know what's gonna happen.
And that's what,
you know,
as real as the guest because you
never know what's going to happen.
But you're not concerned at all
these guys nipping at your heels.
All these guys coming up the ladder.
It's part of the game.
It's what I signed up for.
Yeah.
I,
if I,
if I didn't want to do it,
I wouldn't do it.
You know?
I knew that,
you know,
one day I'll be the champion.
I knew there were people
who come from my built.
Yeah,
I understand that.
And you know,
and you know there's a lot of
good guys out there that I mean,
you know,
like,
find Jvs fretting over
[inaudible] you know Nigga,
I mean they,
I mean they all want a piece of it,
you know,
I understand that no matter who it is
and it's not even you just meet it says
whoever it may when Kane was fighting,
you don't want to overdo them.
You know,
every one of the pieces of the title.
Well you know,
it's an interesting thing too because
what we're seeing today with MMA,
we're seeing this combination like this
marriage of fighting with promotion.
I can't do it.
Yeah,
you're not that guy.
I hate it.
But,
but you not being,
that guy is promotable.
This is what it's like.
It's almost like,
no.
First of all,
I don't think the UFC has enough resources
to promote every fighter adequately.
Cause I think UFC is a promotional entity,
but it's also like this sanctioning body,
you know,
like the,
not the sanctioning body,
but they're the ones
who put on the fights.
They're the ones who decide who fights
and you've got a 500 fighter roster.
Whereas like in other
organizations you would have a,
you know,
you would have a bunch of different
venues and avenues for different fighters.
Could go when a guy like you
is the heavyweight champion,
blue collar guy works as a firefighter.
You know,
you've got a great story,
you're a fun guy.
Like does it frustrate you that
people expect you to talk shit and,
and get,
I mean you,
you've seen all these guys
that are getting a lot of
attention now for obviously
Conners the master
at it,
right?
Yeah.
But you're seeing other guys that are,
you know,
trying that route,
trying to say outrageous
shit to try to get attention,
you know.
Yeah.
I'm not going to be a copy cat.
Um,
it's too exhausting for me to figure out
what I'm willing to say and like what I
want to say and hurt someone's feelings.
I don't like,
I don't care.
And like I got more important
shit to worry about.
Like,
yeah,
like my kitchen,
I had to figure out to fix that.
Like,
I don't,
I need to worry about that.
And you knew at a new worry about like
what next I was in a fight was going to
say what was going to say to my,
like,
I'm good man.
I'm just gonna do my thing.
I'm going to go on there.
I'm going to beat your ass.
I'm gonna walk out.
I'm the champ.
I'm torn because on one hand I'm like,
I love a good shit talking session.
I like shit.
Talking like this.
And even at the fire station all day,
man,
I thought I should talk to the bathroom,
you know?
But like,
I just don't want to go home away
and just put someone's feelings.
I don't even know.
Yeah.
But like Colby Covington,
like he's making a name for himself,
but he's making a name for himself,
not just beating good
guys like Damien Maia,
but talking mad shit.
Yeah,
like talking shit in Brazil.
You see only for resale we're doing,
we hit him in the head with it
because he had to go to court for that.
I think that I go to corporate and I think
a couple of weeks he's got to fly all
the way to Australia to
go to court for that.
It's crazy to let it go.
Fucking bowling.
Right.
It wasn't trying to hit him.
I mean it wasn't trying to kill him.
He just threw whatever
he had in his hands.
I Dunno.
It's pretty sweet though.
Fine.
Give him a little fun in Australia.
Yeah,
it's great.
Yeah.
It's like hitting someone
the head with a Koala bear.
Right.
A bottle of vegemite
or something like that.
Oh God.
It's all that stuff.
So salty.
I like that stuff.
Yeah,
I do.
I did one time,
it was so salty as good with butter,
with butter on bread.
Um,
but the,
the,
that thing,
like has there been any pressure on you
to try to talk some shit to try to like
promote things more?
No.
I mean dude telling me like,
you're your own promoter.
I'm like,
well,
okay.
That's what they say to you.
Like how does the UFC say it?
Like,
I mean,
no,
I mean it just,
I dunno,
like I don't really care what they think.
Well,
I'm going to do like promoting
like I promote myself.
That's why you guys are
in a promoting company.
That's what you're supposed to do.
You guys do that,
you know,
I just,
I think they'd rather,
you know,
50 50 with it,
but I don't see it that way.
Well,
I think they would rather someone
who's just promotes themselves.
Like Conor McGregor is a preppy example,
but he's a fucking Unicorn.
Like every now and then one
guy comes along that has,
first of all,
yeah,
it was it an entire country behind him.
Like I'd never seen anything like that.
Like Ireland is on a big country,
but it seems like they're the
biggest country in the world.
When is fighting and
he's fighting in Vegas.
It gets an American and there's
more Irish people in the audience.
I mean,
that's just bananas,
right?
But when they got a guy like that,
they kind of get spoiled.
Like,
Hey,
what,
this is the how you got to do it.
You gotta do like Connor does it.
Well not everybody's Connor,
you know,
so like for a guy like you to see all
these guys getting a lot of attention and
they're very good fighters as well until
Congress case great fighters as well.
But the thing is the
shit talking like that.
That's sort of what's
ramping everything up.
That's what's getting all these
people to buy the paper view.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean if someone came at me,
you know,
you're forced to defend myself.
I'm pretty ready.
I mean I'm a fireman.
I get shit talked to her day by you know,
five or six guys.
So like I got,
like I said,
like I just want to go home away and just,
just,
I have other stuff to worry about
like training wise and like,
and what am I going to
tweet today when I went,
when it was too much made jail sentence.
Career.
Yeah.
I mean I think than being a great fighter,
but I did chills like career really
took off when he started talking shit.
If people remember chill in
the early days of his career,
he was a gentleman.
He never talked shit,
but then somewhere along
the line he's like,
Anderson Silva,
you absolutely suck my belt and it's like
a WWE promotion and everybody's going
crazy and shale took it to a new level,
like jail opened up the
door to a lot of shit.
Talkers of the modern era.
It really let them know like,
look,
the guy promoted the fuck out of here.
Take classes or any of that.
I'm not trying to be funny.
Like,
I mean he's just very smart.
Yeah,
we talked to him.
No.
Yeah,
he's very intelligent,
very smart.
I did a couple of his radio shows.
Exceptionally smart and very articulate,
very.
He's got a great vocabulary
and just knows right there.
I have no vocabulary.
I'm at articulate.
I'm the year you get just,
I think I always said that
like people just need to,
it's,
it's almost like there's no way.
I mean other than like maybe having
a podcast or something like that,
there's no,
and I know that Tyron does that now.
Tyron Woodley has his own podcast and I
think a couple of other guys may be as
well,
but it's hard.
It's hard for people to get to know you.
All they see is this stoic fireman.
He goes out there and fucks people up.
You know they're not,
which should be enough.
Who doesn't want that?
That's what I say.
I should be enough.
But it's like,
it's hard.
I think it's hard for the UFC to
figure out how to promote everybody.
No.
Yeah,
I understand.
I mean there's fiber people
on the roster and all that,
so yeah,
definitely.
Um,
yeah,
whatever it is,
what it is or we need to do while
he made everyone happy weight.
I think the embeddeds
helped me out a little bit.
Yes.
I think better.
It's a great,
I think those out.
Yeah.
They help you out a lot.
I get the chance to see.
We really,
honestly,
I was living in the comments is either
as I'm to lose or my wife's got a fat
ass.
Both might be true,
but there's nothing wrong with the,
you know,
first of all,
I can't read the comments.
I love it.
I laugh,
I laugh.
Sorry.
Back in the day.
Back in the day when I lost
the street right there,
like I was like,
people would write me like not want
to tell how bad a person I was.
I should kill myself.
That was the worst fighter
America and I was in the world.
I'm like,
oh my God.
Well God,
and the wife's like,
stop reading it.
So I deleted my Facebook account,
my personal,
yeah,
I deleted it.
I want it.
And then,
then I came my epiphany.
I said,
I'm screwed.
I don't care anymore.
It's now if you're watching
me Instagram once in a while,
the tag the tag or something,
they'll be like,
well job Joe,
it's over your skin.
You know?
Say say something stupid.
Like he was like,
you're a paper champion.
I was like,
he's like,
he's a fake.
It's a paper champion.
I'm like,
I know.
Do totally fake and paper champion.
Do Zass beat you?
I mean,
that's what I'll put out.
It's me.
It's not about me.
And he's the guy guys like,
and then we'll put a word.
I'm like,
what the fuck,
man?
I come back with me something man,
like,
you know,
Nah,
don't guys laughing.
I just think it's funny and shit.
But isn't it kind of a waste of
energy to engage those people?
You actually enjoy it.
I actually enjoy it.
I have the people usually hit me
up on a message and then like,
Bro,
hugs love a champ.
I just want him to get
a reaction out of me.
I'm like,
Oh,
you're that guy,
that guy.
Those guys are the saddest.
But it's also like after this true fight,
you were at your lowest,
so you're reading comments
when you actually lost.
Now you're reading comments.
When you're the heavyweight
champion of the world,
it's like,
what are you going to say bitch?
It's true.
The fuck.
I say,
kiss the rain.
The worst thing you know they could
say is they can't say anything.
You fucking,
you're the champ.
Yeah,
you're going to lose some day.
That's the worst thing they could say.
Yeah,
most likely.
I mean,
if you keep going,
eventually can kick your ass.
That's gonna suck everybody.
If you keep going,
we'll lose.
Including Mayweather,
including everybody who's ever lived.
If you keep going long enough,
yeah,
father time will kick.
Your ass will be there to help him out.
I go more my three acres
once a week and I'm like,
I get down.
I'm like,
oh,
how old are you?
I'm 35 you're still all right.
You still got a couple
of years ahead of us.
They say,
but you're later in life.
Not when I cut the grass bra.
I feel like I'm mad.
In fact,
I get down at my back is like tight
and sore and my God damn cutting grass.
I got a big scag man.
I fly around,
I get done and I wake up in the morning.
I'm like,
oh,
like everything hurts.
I'm like,
what's a big SCAG Scott?
It's a 61 inch.
Like it's like a commercial lawnmower.
Oh you got one of them.
Babbel just seems like fun.
Oh it's flies.
But that,
that hurts your back.
Yeah.
Cause I'm always balancing like,
oh,
it's not perfect level.
Sometimes the fucking daily
grind of MMA training,
like what that's gotta be doing to your
body that like when you were talking
about how you barely get out of bed,
like some days most people would think
like they see you fighting like this
fucking guy just doing cartwheels all
around his house all day and it's so bad.
Like I'll wake up in the
morning and the life like,
Hey,
I'm like,
show Kimmy coffee.
she wants you to get her a coffee.
It's right.
It's right to do it.
Jab,
Jab.
I guess I'm fourth in my coffee.
I'm like for them,
my house man,
it's like her,
the dogs on me.
Like I guess I'm there to pay the bills,
man.
I got to give me a sense for you though.
I really do.
I think that's healthy to have
somebody gotta answer to sometimes.
I love it honestly.
Like,
you know,
she takes care of me,
man.
She does a lot for me and so
it's at least I could do for,
you know what I mean?
She's a good woman.
She,
she like,
like I said,
we had that big storm.
I had no idea what to do.
She called insurance should
be screened with them,
get more shit.
We didn't,
we knew that we needed and I wouldn't.
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
that's fine.
Who gave me like a check him,
I'm fine with it.
You should film like you getting
out of bed in the morning.
Maybe we should do something like that
for like Instagram to look an Instagram
video.
You here we go.
I mean people just don't,
they don't know because
we'll their singing is you
kaolin for breezy over doing,
knocking out junior dos Santos,
raising your hands,
you know,
all of the glory moments.
I think that's one of the things that
embedded does really well is they show
like,
hey,
this is a fucking grind for weeks and
weeks and weeks and weeks until you get
into a cage for a fist fight and this is
a fucking brutal way to get by in life.
I could go 30 seconds or 25 minutes,
which of course rather
go 30 seconds and when,
but yeah,
maybe they should do something
like that for this fight.
Like really like follow
you from beginning to end.
Like fuck.
See,
see what it's like when you're getting
up in the morning and then just put it
together for something after the fight.
Yeah.
You know?
I mean it sucks on some days man.
You know,
like,
you know,
some days I'm all right
by the days I'm like,
God damn.
It said,
I'm so sorry.
Like,
you know me,
I'm like,
man,
this sucks.
I got to sleep wrong.
Like unfortunately we let
the dog sleep in bed with us,
so I get like one eighth of the bed,
a king size bed.
So
like a skydiver.
Yeah.
I'm like,
I mean cousin covers please.
You know,
like,
yeah,
the dog's a fart in your face.
Last night was so bad,
man,
Primo guy.
That dude in high stage last night.
Yeah.
I had her move.
My dog was watching TV with me last night,
farting up a storm to not cool.
It's the worst.
But when do you like have a,
like how do you know when to call it?
Like if you get up in the morning and
your white real fucking sore and you just
can't,
how do you know when like
maybe I should take today off?
I usually know by that night.
The night before.
Yeah.
I talked to my coaches,
you know,
and you know,
be like,
Hey,
I didn't feel,
and just on my sparring goes and stuff
like that are grappling wherever I do
some type of my condition,
like my sparring session,
if it's [inaudible] kickboxing
or boxing or digits,
whoever it is,
it's just washing me and they're like,
how are you feeling?
I'm like,
I feel like shit.
And then my guy,
you know,
it's just take tomorrow off and yeah.
Or just know,
take half a day and
then work out at night.
And when you do take a day off,
do you do like ice baths
or like how do you,
uh,
try to accelerate the recovery?
Like ice bath,
Epsom salt or something?
I just,
I actually do know that I sleep all day.
I literally just eat and sleep all day.
Just sleep.
Just catch up my rest.
Yeah,
it's good.
It's interesting though because there's
no real set thing where you can know
when to do it and when not to.
He's got to do it all by feel.
Yeah,
I think,
I think just knowing your body,
I think it's one thing I buy,
I picked up while on since I've started
finding and just knowing my body,
cause you know,
I think God,
you're the best critic on your body.
Cause like back in the day
we was do cave and training,
you know like I feel fine,
you know,
but there's nothing too is like,
we're so used to training a certain way
you can get through those workouts even
if you're tired and sore.
But I can go and pick up a bag
of groceries and blow up my back.
Right,
right.
You pick up a baby or
put to put on my shit.
Like I never have it.
But it just,
you do random stuff that
you don't do every day.
Like you know,
you pick up a bag of groceries out your,
oh my back.
Oh,
you're back was out.
But then I can go and spar five,
five minute rounds and I'm a by his dad.
But yeah,
I can make it through just cause
I'm so used to my by which,
yeah,
that's the weirdest thing,
right.
Was you do the most ridiculous hardcore
shit and then like you just go to tire
shoes wrong and something tweaks.
Yeah.
Like what is that?
Like what's causing that?
Ratchet actually has her,
my Overeem fight sitting there and uh,
we're,
we're both my buddy Ron,
what his parents were hanging out with,
you know,
a couple of cocktails all day drinking.
We're hanging out,
drive around browns stadium on the water
and he has this little like four pound
dog.
I was like,
oh,
what's up little girl?
How you doing?
I go to pick her up and I'm like,
and my back went out after the fight.
Yeah.
Is after the fight,
like a week later we declare how crazy.
I was like,
oh,
but anything like go fully,
fully like I felt to him like,
okay,
we're good.
We're good.
Wow.
So then a couple of days later I do
anything for a couple of days of it.
So I went to spar and hit a AA,
my home,
my pinched nerve in my back and went,
I was out for a whole week.
That's crazy.
From picking up a dog.
Four pound dog.
Fuck that man.
It's like,
what am I mean?
Yeah,
I get,
I get punched in the face by massive
man and then doc fucks me up.
I was a go into Vegas once for a
k one bout way back in the day.
There was so some k one fights in Vegas.
We're going to go watch and I'm
in the shower on the way to like,
like leave the house.
I'm like taking a shower.
Oh this is going to be fun.
Can't wait to see his fights and
I just turn to grab this show,
this soap and something popped in my neck.
I was like fuck.
Out of nowhere.
So I drove to Vegas like
this the entire way,
like four hours.
And every time I had a turn
like to look behind me to park,
I had to literally turned my whole
body like this from just turning to get
grabbed shampoo or something
like just turning ah,
like no idea what it was.
It doesn't make any sense.
We just turned around and just every now
and then and it fucked me up for like
two weeks for like two weeks.
My neck was fucked.
Dao Ji Ji still get adjusted.
No,
didn't get a job.
That's true.
Maybe I should if I was trying to make
sure that should go into wealth checking
doctor,
they kill the fucking duck
and waffle over my head.
Some Buddhist Shit.
Me,
look mate,
I'm not saying they going to
a chiropractor is a bad thing.
Some people,
I'm sure it works,
but you know the history of what,
like how it got started.
I know that a little wacky.
Yeah,
there's a,
there's some pretty good
articles about how wacky it is.
Let me look into it.
But there's a lot of like,
it's interesting because there's a lot
of methods of recovery that some people
swear by like the cupping thing or like
electrical muscular stimulation or you
ever see those Norma tec boots,
they put those things on
your legs if your use those.
No,
no,
no.
Oh those are a,
they're like a,
it's like,
like you're putting on pants,
they go all the way up your legs.
Circulation.
Yeah.
They have like,
they,
they're supposed to be
really good for recovery.
Like it's interesting how so many of
these things and it's like they're just
trying things out and they're trying to
figure out like what works for you and
what doesn't work for you,
you know?
Yeah.
When I had knee surgery,
I bet it's awesome.
Like contraption like around
your leg and she's like,
how,
like compress you want them.
We don't want,
you know,
we're,
eventual get tight.
So she gets a tight announced to the cold
water comes through and they get super
tiny,
constricts it and push it all
the bad blood and you know,
it's,
it's awesome.
I love it.
Would you have done with
the ne it's a scope.
Yeah.
It's my fifth one.
Fifth one.
Holy Shit.
On the same name.
No,
I had two of my writing through my left.
Yeah.
Talking a big guy and be
crippled when I get older.
Do you run?
I do.
I use the antigravity treadmill.
What's an antigravity treadmill?
So I put on these super tight,
these super tight things
and I sit myself up and I,
and he can go like half your body weight,
6% of the body weight,
whatever in the water.
It's air and lifted me up.
Watson.
Really?
It's pretty bad.
Yeah.
Um,
what's the benefit of that?
Just a sit on Paul.
My fees much that it right there.
Yeah,
that's it.
Whoa.
So it doesn't pound your feet like so
cause I'm 240 pounds so I'm going to kill
my feet and my legs and my
knees so it lets me out.
It makes a little bit easier.
But does it,
it can't possibly be giving
you is hard to work out.
Definitely.
I'm running a 9.5 miles per hour.
Right.
But you're running at 9.5 miles per
hour at less than your body weight.
Yeah.
I'm still running a,
you know,
2100 some pounds that a two 40 oh yeah.
So what will happen,
by the way,
I'm wearing 120 pounds and then it's 25%
of them are like 200 something pounds,
whatever it is,
it's still works.
I still,
I get a great sweat.
I'm still breathing hard,
you know what I mean?
It's still pushing myself.
Is that like one of your
main forms of cardio?
Yeah,
that and I do like a lot of pair work.
You know what the sparring,
it's like you don't what sparring.
I do my rounds and I get done.
I do either pair work for like 20 minutes
straight right after and then I do
some my sticks with my coach,
you know,
we're going to have moving,
just keep my studio.
The foam foam.
Yeah.
Boy,
whatever they made,
they made some weird contraption.
Power would.
Do you do any other machines
like a versa climber or any,
anything at swimming?
Do you know any swimming?
No.
No,
no.
I do a lot.
I'll wrestle or I'm sorry,
I started to wrestle here soon.
Know mostly a lot of
his old school training,
which is probably the best way anyway.
Yeah,
I like it.
I mean I run twice a week though,
for sure.
There's no question.
I like running just cause like I run hard
on Mondays and then Fridays is more of
recovery run,
but my body rest,
you know,
you're doing it in this thing.
You're not running on the concrete.
Yeah,
I like running.
I think it just,
it feels so much better.
My legs like I feel a
hundred times better.
Oh,
I couldn't imagine.
I mean especially when you're,
you know,
you're dealing with 240 pounds pounding
on your knees and you've scoped out all
the cartilage and shit.
They're doing some stuff now though.
You should look into like talk
to Dr. Davidson from the UFC.
Yeah.
The shooting stem cells and to knees
and regenerating cartilage and meniscus
tissue and you're getting
into that for sure.
I mean I definitely want to get knee
replacement with when I'm older.
So new replacement where
I don't want to have that.
Oh No,
no,
I don't want that.
Yeah,
exactly.
I don't think that you're going
to have to do that anymore.
I think soft tissue stuff,
they're going to be able to fix that.
Oh,
thank God.
Yeah.
They're pretty,
they're pretty damn close.
There'll be,
they're able to do some
pretty incredible shit now.
And um,
there's the interior
teeth now.
Really?
Yeah.
My wife just person harm.
They grow your teeth.
They can grow your tea like the PRP,
like it's something like that.
Whoa.
Hold on a sec.
Really Jamie,
we'll find it.
They grow your teeth,
put a little scaffolding or some kind and
then they use some injection to regrow
teeth.
I don't know if it's in full use yet,
but like,
it's definitely on the way.
If it's not going to be able
to grow all kinds of shit,
they're going to be
able to grow body parts,
our great grandchildren,
they're going to cut their hands off
and grow new ones that they don't think
they look good.
Yeah.
Kids going to be like my hands,
like to ugly.
I wanted long,
slender finger.
So I caught them off like that.
That's the world we're
going to be living in.
Yeah.
It's going to be superficial.
Well,
not just superficial,
but bizarre.
Like you're gonna be able to re,
you know,
they've already regenerated a
bunch of different body parts.
Like this one woman had bladder cancer
and so they made her a new bladder with
her own skin.
They used her own skin and I'm used stem
cells and grew her bladder in a petri
dish and then put it back in her body.
Great.
Works Great.
It is.
I haven't talked to her about her pee.
The promise of growing new teeth,
dental stem cells could revolutionize
treatment for patients who face
extractions.
Wow.
Growing new teeth.
Fuck what a weird world we're living in.
Right.
That's got to feel good for you though.
It'd be thinking about the future,
like all the stuff you're
doing yourself right now,
all the injuries and getting banged up,
squirt some stuff in
there and fix everything.
I'm cool with that.
I'm good with that.
All right.
Steepy.
So,
uh,
January 20th,
everybody should watch UFC heavyweight
championship live from Boston,
Massachusetts.
I'll be there.
I can't wait.
Good luck to you,
brother.
Thanks for doing the show,
man.
John.
Oh,
for sure.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Steve Bay,
Meo chick heavyweight champ of the world.
Let these bitches know.
Well,
Cleveland's in the house.
Oh,
H I.
L
I know.